what is method writing
oh you're starting off with a hard
question
well i
i'm an actor and
method acting
is a
a big school of acting that marlon
brando and people like that studied
under marilyn monroe and so forth and i
studied method acting and it stresses
um
an authentic
response to what your work is you're not
acting with gestures you're you're being
true you're being
natural and
i was teaching writing
in which i thought
i wanted writers not to worry about the
technique or the style
to begin with but to get in touch with
their their center their
their true voice
so
i called it method writing
like method acting method writing
and that was the basic idea
method writing is a much more
complicated
methodology of learning to write
from your deep truth
and there are a lot of other techniques
i teach that are about cinematic images
so in a sense you're making a movie in
the reader's head so there's other
things you have to know how to do
but the core of it just like with acting
is to be centered and to be true
so
method
writing is references method acting
how easy is that for someone
just does it
do we think that we're being true and in
actuality we're actually putting on
errors and the audience can see that
and they can see it in our writing
well if it was easy to do that there
would be no
uh everybody would be acting
it's not easy to do that that's why
people take acting classes
uh i always ask people what do you learn
what's the first thing you learn to do
in an acting class and the answer is how
not to act
how not to look like you're acting
because
if you've ever been to a play there's
always some
some guy that's overacting and you sense
it right away
and as soon as you see the cat the
person
acting
you're pulled back from the reality of
the
play now of course the play's not real
you know it's a play
but while you're watching it you want to
have the feeling
that it's real
matter of fact they instead of saying
you believe it
the
theater expression is you suspend your
disbelief
because you know it's not hamlet you
know you know these are actors
but what you what you want to create is
the feeling of verisimilitude truth so
that the people in the audience for that
hour and a half two hours
can suspend their disbelief and fall
into it well if you have an actor
overacting uh you know right away that
they're an actor and you can't get into
it
um that's why people study acting to
learn how not to act to learn how to be
natural because
it's very easy to be natural in your
home when you're sitting there smoking a
cigar and drinking a beer
but let's see you be natural on a stage
with 500 people out there and you know
lights hitting you from above
or in a movie where there's a you know a
camera looking right at your eye and
there's the guy with the sound boom and
you know 20 people around you let's see
you relax and be real in that situation
and that takes training
now when you get to writing
people don't realize when they're not
writing authentically because they they
learn
to sound like writers
they learn to be poetic they learn to be
eloquent and they develop a lot of bad
habits
in the attempt to look like they're
writers
quote unquote
so it's very hard to get people to write
in an authentic way
it's hard to get people to act in an
authentic way but harder to get them to
write in an authentic way because they
really don't believe
that they are not writing in a natural
voice they they they have all this fancy
junk that they write but they think it's
oh it's some a writer
look at me ma but
very hard to do that to get to your
natural
what i call the deep voice
that takes focus and it takes practice
and training just like an athlete
you know an athlete's got to be able to
perform with a lot of pressure and act
like there's no no pressure you know you
can't choke so
it's the same with writing you
you're doing something that's unnatural
you know you're right if i were writing
a shopping list
i wouldn't
be uptight but all of a sudden i'm
writing my great american novel my great
poem
and you know i'm i'm suddenly going to
be no i'm a poet
i'm a writer blah blah blah
and you start to push
so it's very hard to let go of that and
just be real and be authentic and it
takes training
is it hard to write a good story
is it hard to write a good story um
no
it's not hard to write a good story
it's hard to write a great story
and the only way you're going to write a
great story is to be willing to write a
shitty story
when you try to write a good story
you're in big trouble
just like with acting when you try to
be acting
you're in trouble
so
again you've got to be calm
you've got to be simple
and if you if you write truly
sometimes you might write a bad story
sometimes you might write a crappy story
but if you're always trying to write a
good story
you'll never
write a great story
but if you're willing to fail
and write a bad story or a crappy story
once in a while you get lucky and then
you get a great story
so for me it's like going to the races
i'd rather pick a winner that's a long
shot and makes a lot of money than win a
lot of little races that pay only two
dollars
so yeah it's easy to write a good story
it's hard to write a great story
you mentioned willingness to fail
with some of your students or others
that you've seen
is there something in them that they're
too rigid and they can't let go of the
idea of being perfect and doing
everything great or excellent at first
pass yeah i mean i could just quote what
you just said but you see
you've got to understand that as i said
it's very easy to be sitting home in
your living room having a beer and a
cigar
and be natural but let's see you'd be
natural in front of an
audience of 500 people or in front of a
the lens of a of a camera you'd like in
a movie and that lens is you know it's
right up against your face man you freak
out you get nervous you push you you
overdo it so when you're writing it's
it's a little hard to relax
and just
just be honest
be true and get to your deep voice i
have techniques in writing for how to
get to the deep voice i have a thing
called the transformation line
which is a
a certain kind of statement that you
as i say you massage it
it means you take it deeper and you you
go deeper and deeper into it
but when you're doing that you can't be
thinking of your plot or your story and
again everybody when they start to write
they they first think of a story
they think of what they're going to
write about
death
if you know what you're going to write
about before you write about it you're
in trouble
but most people don't want to write
about what they don't know they're going
to write about because then it might not
be good and no one wants to take that
chance so they start out with hmm what
can i write about oh i know all right
about that time my
my grandfather slipped and fell off the
roof into the fish pond yeah that'll
make a good story and then they put a
little start to write a good what they
think is a good story instead of just
approaching the writing
from nothing a very zen kind of an idea
you begin with nothing and see where it
wants to go
most people don't want to risk that
because if you do that you might write
something bad
and
people don't want to fail
but if you're willing to fail
then sometimes you you strike it rich
can those who are worried so much about
failure do exercises to
lessen that
to make themselves feel either more at
home on the stage or at home
bearing
their words to people that might
criticize them well i do use the term
exercises um in
stanislavski who did method acting
he's got the word concepts
and
i also
was in second city and did
improvisational theater and even taught
classes in it
they use something called theater games
so if anyone ever watches that tv show
um
[Music]
what's the name of it whose line is it
anyway
they always have a little game they have
to play
so you you have these
points of focus an exercise a theater
game a concept and you learn these
concepts and if you focus on the concept
then you're not focused on the story so
you can actually practice that but
when you say an exercise
to me
every time you write you're doing an
exercise
when i'm in rehearsal for a play and
then opening night comes i don't
suddenly go oh it's opening night i can
act
what you've been rehearsing
is not acting
in the whole
six weeks of two weeks of your rehearsal
you're rehearsing to be true so when
opening night comes you don't suddenly
start acting you are continuing to do
that work so to me
the exercise is what you do when you are
writing
and if you fail
now we go into a different issue
which is an issue for a lot of people
who are successful in life
with anything
people who are successful in life with
anything
they interpret failure
differently
than people who tend to be unsuccessful
when
when people
tend to be unsuccessful
they interpret failure as evidence that
they're not good at that
so then they try something else
successful people whether you're a
writer or an insurance salesman or a
banker or whatever a bank robber you
know applies to everything
when you have
learning how to juggle
okay i'm supposed to drop the ball a
hundred times
i don't drop the ball
once and twice and then i think well i
can't juggle
i go
yeah that's that's what happens when you
learn how to do something you fail
so a successful person they interpret
failure
as
what's supposed to happen
you're supposed to fail and then you
keep doing it and you fail some more and
you fail more or as samuel beckett said
fail
try again
fail again try again
fail better
in other words i'm supposed to fail and
when i fail it means i'm on the road
toward learning how to juggle
successfully so that's the real
difference
and the way to prevent failure is to
always aim for good
because
ultimately everybody can be good
but to be great means you have to risk
failing
and unless you're willing to risk
failing you won't be great so when
people fail at something they go oh i
guess i'm not good at that but
successful people interpret failure as
yeah i'm supposed to fail
and i'll keep failing and eventually
i'll get better and i'll learn how to
juggle and i'll learn how to do it
so that's the key it's not about failing
it's how you interpret failure that's
the big difference
and you're more nervous than i am oh
yeah no i get very nervous but i i'm
hoping to i like it yeah fail better
each time and and not just aim for good
well see that's another thing
my acting teacher used to always say
uh when you're nervous before
performance don't try to get rid of the
nervousness
bring it with you into the scene
because it's a it's an authentic emotion
and as he put it never deny
an authentic emotion on stage or in
front of a camera never deny it never
try to cover it up so if in the middle
of a scene you start laughing laugh
if in the middle of the scene you're
nervous let that nervousness be there
when i do a poetry reading i am always
ask my wife she'll tell you my palms get
sweaty and i'm a wreck
and and i want to be i know that's good
i go okay good it means i'm alive
because if i was dead i wouldn't be
nervous but if you're alive you're
afraid of failure and if when you're
afraid of making a fool of yourself in
front of
20 or 100 people you get nervous well
that's good i should be nervous
and what i try to do is not to dissipate
it
the nervousness is really my friend
because it means i am connected to this
moment when i get up and i open
you know my book of poetry and i go okay
my first poem is gonna be you know blah
blah blah
if if i'm confident i i i'm gonna be
boring you know confidence is
really pretty boring you know there's
nothing worse than seeing somebody
think they know everything it's it's
boring when you're performing when
you're acting when you're reading
so if you are nervous
hold on to it
it's your friend
let it be
and when you start to read whatever that
poem is a story
if the poem makes you
you're nervous
it's because there's something at stake
you might be writing about
the time your father came home drunk and
you
you tried to stop him from leaving and
you pushed him down and he fell and
here you are 12 years old and you feel
like you just
knocked your dad out
or
maybe you're writing a poem about when
you were in
in italy and
you were 19 and you got a phone call
from the father
of the boy you were traveling with
and he tells your son you have to come
home you're the man in the family now
and you don't even want to
admit that you know what that means so
you say
what i i don't understand of course you
understand
he's telling your father died but you
know what i don't understand he said son
you're the man in the family now
well
you know that's that's a moment that i
really relive and
remember it was like my whole world
caved in
i was in lake como in italy and
uh it just changed my life it just
i i never thought that would happen i
my father was like the most important
man in my life
and uh
if you're writing something about that
then you should be nervous
it should
bring you into the
heart of your
feelings whatever there might be for me
it was
absolute terror
just terror that i would not know what
to do
i felt my father was the wisest
man i ever knew
and that even though i was 19 i felt
that
he would tell me the secret of life
and he hadn't told it to me yet but he
was going to
and
when he died i thought
i'll never know what the secret of life
is i'll never know
how to survive
because i want to be an artist and i
don't know how you make a living as an
artist
so maybe he would tell me but he wasn't
there anymore and i was like lost for
years
because of that and even now when i'm
talking about it i'm
i'm getting all
i'm feeling that feeling i had when i
was just
scared shitless
about life
that i wouldn't know what to do and you
know the funny thing about it is
it's been
i don't know 60 years since my dad died
and
i'm still not sure i know what the
secret of life is and i'm still not sure
i know how to survive i can't believe
i've survived this long but i have but i
don't believe it i don't
i don't get it i don't understand it i
don't know how people survive
you know i always think they know
something i don't know
so
nervousness is good
how are how are father's days for you
how what father's day june 20th how was
that father's day
you mean when
when i'm the father of my son and
any any time father's day comes up
i
i you know once my son was born it was
more a question of me being the father
to him
and so that's what father's day was for
me that you know he would
uh get me something or write me a card
and every card he wrote i've saved them
i've got him on the on my bookshelves
you know so i can see him and
you know he always would make me a
father's day card um
you know i never thought about that
um
i i think about my father so much or did
think about him so much that i don't
think i reserved one day that today is
going to be the day i think about him i
thought about my father
so much especially when i was
unsure or in trouble or
worried or whatever i would think what
would my father do what would he say
what would
wha you know what would he tell me
so i i don't need father's day you know
i
but
he died when he was 54
i think
so when i made 54
i remember thinking
okay
because i always thought will you live
to be as old as he was
at the time 54 seemed like
a very old but when i was 54 i i felt
like i just got started my son was about
five years old so i became a father when
i was 49.
so um you know i uh
at 54 i thought okay
all the okay now it's it's it's me
you know it's not him now it's
now
you know it's my turn i've got to do it
so that was a big year for me when when
i had turned 54.
was it easy for you to write about this
i've written about my relationship with
my father many times
in different ways
and my mother too who was a
kind of a
crazy
according to my therapist a paranoid
schizophrenic
so i wrote about my mother too but i've
written about my father
i've written about
being a father when josh was born and i
would have to go to safeway and get
diapers and enfamil the the milk you
know that you drink
so i've written about father issues
quite a bit
you know bukowski has that great poem
about his own father
when he goes to his house after his
father dies and he puts on
his father's suit
which hangs on him a little
loose
um the poem is called the twins
because he looks at himself in the
mirror and he thinks
okay now i'm my father
so we could be twins
so
i guess you wrestle with your father one
way or the other those who've had good
fathers those who had bad fathers
my dad was
wise man
a great man loved by everyone
he also had a problem uh he was an
alcoholic and a lot of anxiety in my
family growing up i'm a quote
adult child of alcoholics you know that
that was the thing
um
but i didn't i don't know if i wrote
about him a lot
after i got to be 54. i think at that
point i kind of
thought well okay
i got this far without knowing anything
maybe i can i can go the rest of the way
without knowing anything
and i still don't know anything you know
every day when i wake up in the morning
i said
you know i i try to guess what time it
is by the light
you know the light outside that
beginning of dawn
and i try to guess what time it is and
i'll i'll look over and i'll see what
time it is and i'll think to myself
okay another day
another day to
write your poems and teach and
be you know love your friends and love
the world
so
that's a long answer to to a very simple
question you asked
where's the green tape
no i don't want you to talk it's great
i like it
i know there's a lot of emotion i
remember there was a clerk
at a grocery store and i'd seen the
person many times and i was sort of
friendly with them and and
i'm not it was father's day
and the clerk
so i forgot what happened and he said
you're not wishing me a happy father's
day and i could see how hurt he was
and he goes you think that just because
i'm older i don't you know and i could
just see it was like a real wound to
this person yeah and i i said to him you
know the reason i didn't wish you that
is because
father's day wasn't a thing for me i
never knew mine so that was why so we
were both coming to it with these two
different things but yeah i could see
even
he was he was still you know this was
very hard for him and here he was behind
this cashier trying to save face and you
know i just remember that being a very
um interesting moment i never forgot it
yeah we don't have a lot of moments like
that with
people we don't know
i kind of knew him just just i would
joke with him and
and i actually never saw him after that
i don't know what happened to him but
hopefully he's okay but um anyway i'm
going off on a tangent but i guess what
i'm trying to say is that we don't know
some you know fatherhood motherhood all
those things are very these are very
sort of deep you talk about the deep
voice that yeah these are things that we
all carry our own
wound or whatever with us you know yeah
and
um
you don't know whether you're supposed
to play a role or
what is it to be a father
you know i
i remember when my wife was pregnant
i
when she called me on the phone to tell
me she was pregnant
the first thought i thought was okay now
now it begins
meaning i have to take life seriously
and then the night
her water broke we were watching
sleeping with the enemy
a movie on tv
and it was about 11 o'clock at night
you know
you you always want your water to break
in the morning so you can go to the
hospital
and you've had a good night's sleep but
no it was 11 o'clock at night we were
exhausted and water breaks and we're
driving
to the to kaiser and i i stop at a
ralph's or something and i get ice
because they said something about
you know she can have ice or something
like that i don't know what it was but i
went into the
ralphs with the neon lights and
everything was real bright
and it was 11 11 30 at night
and again i just had that got a little
ice chest put the ice in i remember
thinking
okay this is it
you know
we knew it was a boy your son's going to
be born
very soon
and your life is going to totally change
so there was that feeling that
everything was going to be different
well nothing really changes you just go
on day by day
being and dealing with what you have to
deal with
but in my imagination i thought you know
it was like okay showtime you know it's
like you're doing a play and they go
you're on and then you have to walk out
there and
i'm the father
where's my lines and they go uh
uh there are no lines i go what do you
mean i go well we don't have any lines
well there's got to be lines i mean i'm
a father what's what's the
what's the you know what's the role what
do i got to do and they go oh i don't
know and they go are you a father yeah
but i don't know what the hell to do
well
anybody here know what to do no
i'm in front of 500 people here what am
i going to do
well you got to be a father yeah but
what is that about i don't know
so you just go and do it
you know that whatever role you think it
is it's not what you think it's going to
be
i remember
when josh was
in
third grade
i was driving him to school and my son
is very stubborn i don't know where he
gets it
i think he gets it for me of course
he's really stubborn i mean you know you
don't tell josh what to do
and we're in the car and i don't know we
got into something he and i and my wife
would always say
don't make it a fight you know
i couldn't help it you know i'm gonna
hold my position he's gonna hold his
and before you know it i'm kind of
yelling and screaming and
we're just driving it's a mess
we get to school and it was my day to go
to the kids and teach them how to write
poetry
so i tell them you know write about
something true and
anyway
i walk around the room and watch what
the kids are writing just to see if
they're doing okay sometimes a kid maybe
doesn't quite know how to get started
and i help him and there's my son
writing about me
yelling and screaming in the car
now i usually have the kids get up and
read
and there was no way i could
not have him do it if he wanted to
because
i that would be a bad lesson to teach
him
so when it was time to read i said okay
who wants to read first
josh raises the sand
i go
so he walks up opens it up and he's
writing about being in the car with his
dad who's yelling and screaming
and the kids are like
i mean they're they're loving it and at
the same time they're a little shocked
and i know they're all looking at me
they want to see how am i going to react
to it
and i just listened to it like i was
listening to a piece of writing and then
when he was finished i went
good good i said you know the part there
where you mentioned that you could write
a little more about that you know make
it now as i responded to it like it was
a piece of writing worthy of being
commented on
uh
but
you know how do you plan for something
like that
you know
there are the kids i'm the teacher and
he's writing about me and you know being
a kind of uh not very empathetic father
so
you know i don't know whatever's in the
handbook
it wasn't in the handbook i got you just
sort of stumble your way through and
hope you do your best
i think that's why in
saving private ryan
um
at the very end of the movie
when he he goes to the grave
of the major who saved his life
and you know he's an old man now and and
he
hopes that
that
his life was worthy of being saved
i broke down in the movie theater
because
the way i related to it was
at that point when i saw the movie i
hope my life will be worthy
as a father as a husband as a friend and
a man i was just
it's probably the most i've cried in a
movie ever in my life when he said i
hope my life will be worthy
so
you make a lot of mistakes you fail
right
you fail and when you fail you you got
to go
well this is what's supposed to happen
and
that day that josh wrote this piece
about the car ride over that was the
deeper voice
yeah it was a deep voice and he was
writing about something that was
like pretty brave gutsy of him to write
about that
you know i mean i'm his father i'm the
teacher
i'm coming into the classroom as the
teaching everyone how to write and i'm
telling them
a matter of fact
i read a poem by my own father come to
think of it that's part of the lesson so
he went and did it you know bravo for
him
so
like i said you
i i had to validate that i couldn't
one tell him no no don't read that josh
it'll make me look bad
well if it made me look bad too bad
because what he wrote was good
and as a teacher and as a father i have
to reinforce for him
that this is how you make art
you tell the truth
you
you take risks
you write about
what's hard to write about
you see in literature there are four
basic voices or tonalities well
five
if you count
your own voice
your natural
speaking voice as a writer
so the other four there's only four
other tonalities in all of western
literature
and um
i have a standing
offer to any of my students
if they can comb any piece of writing
from homer to the present
and find a page or a paragraph or even
one sentence
that's not one of those four
then i will give them
and and i have a one of those play money
says a billion dollars and i hold up the
billion dollar bill and i go if you can
find your sentence it's not one of those
four
and i hold up the billion dollar bill
say i'll give you a billion dollars and
so far no one has collected it so
there's only four basic
styles or tones or voices depending on
how you want to look at it in all of
western literature beside
writing in your own
your own tone and then there's the other
four
and those other four are
uh tommy billy sarah and becky oh okay
oh i know becky yeah
um
well
one of them is what i call straight talk
all the the the names i use come from a
poem
by another writer so nikki giovanni has
a poem called straight talk
so i use that
in other words and these would all be
writing in your own voice
i cover that
how to get the voice deep and all that
in my uh my first book on method writing
called method writing
and then
the four voices
that you just asked me about
i cover in my second book
it's called advanced method writing and
at the bottom it says the art of tonal
dynamics so it's how to take these four
tones and use them the way uh
a composer of music would use
different kinds of musical percussion
effects and
you know whatever because tones change
in music
very deep and then suddenly it becomes
light and so forth so the four tones
that i have i have names for him
straight talk means you're not in the
deep voice
you're very chit chatting
everything is boy you won't believe what
happened last night i mean there i am
standing on the corner and would you
believe it a guy comes up and he's got a
cigarette in his nose and i thought you
know very chit chatty the opposite of
the deep voice
the second voice is
uh that writerly
poetic style
that a lot of writers use and that a lot
of writers think you're supposed to
write like that where you give metaphors
and similes and fancy description and
all that kind of stuff
and on a scale of one to ten you could
do it in a subtle way or you could do it
in a very extreme way so for instance if
you
read william faulkner or marcel proust
these are writers who write in a very
ornate style
almost out of ten
but then there are other writers who use
a little bit of style but they're only
at a one or a two but it's all
not writing in your natural voice it's a
heightened style
then the third voice is the oldest
technique in all of writing
it's where you repeat it goes to the
bible
you know it goes all the way back to the
bible where you
you repeat things three times four times
five times so a lot of your great
politicians or preachers will use this
voice i have a dream
that one day blah blah blah blah blah i
have a dream that one day blah blah blah
blah blah i have a dream that one day
blah blah blah
nobody remembers the blah blah blah
but everybody remembers the i have a
dream speech because by repeating it he
makes that a kind of drum beat a
rhythmic pulse
so that is the most ancient form of
writing that was how
people remembered because
people couldn't read
so
even if someone wrote something they
would they would perform it
the repetition of phrases uh it was the
best of times it was the worst of times
from charles dickens or the bible
there's a time to
to be born and a time to die a time to
plant and the time to sow a time to buy
in a time you know the repetition
creates a way to remember
because
people couldn't
read so
you had to know to remember so that
device that repetition is a technique
that can be used
in more ways than you realize so when i
teach it first people have to know how
to do it you know it's just how to do it
then you learn many different ways you
can use it there can be subsets of the
repetition with different repetitions
abraham lincoln's gettysburg address see
these people around that time
they studied what was called the the
greek and latin revival and that was one
of the things you studied if you went
into politics or into religious
preaching was the repetition you studied
that so lincoln's gettysburg address
comes directly from that
where you you repeat something he talks
about in the gettysburg address we've
come here to uh dedicate a portion of
this field as a final resting place of
those who here gave their lives that you
know we may live blah blah blah and then
he goes but in a larger sense we cannot
dedicate we cannot consecrate we cannot
hallow this ground
so we cannot we cannot we cannot if
237 words i think is the gettysburg
address if you go through it you will
find five or six places where lincoln
repeats something like a mantra three
four sometimes five times in a row and
he does it at the very end
at the very end that this nation
shall have a new birth of freedom
and something something
what is it do you remember how he ends
his speech
of the people
by the people
for the people
so that's a repetition that is a
technique that he learned
in in his studies
so that's the third voice
then the fourth one
is actually not a voice it's where you
use language
in a
non-communicative way
where you're writing
almost stream of consciousness or or
absurd images or
maybe you've got someone who's got
alzheimer's or someone is drunk but it's
language that is not used in a normal
linear way and poets and writers have
been doing that for at least over a
hundred years started in france with
arthur rambo and baudelaire and and then
the russian futurists were doing it they
created the thing called zom poetry that
didn't make sense and so forth so any
writing that is kind of like modern art
where you have cubism or abstract
painting or abstract expressionism where
you're just seeing a lot of crap on the
canvas well what would be the analogy of
that with words well it would be words
and sentences that don't make any sense
in other words i did a whole book
of what i and i called it absence of
field because there's no
logical feel to it it's all disconnected
on the page so i kind of took that idea
and i have a book called lucky finds
in which i put it all on card so when
you when you got my book
oh i'm back
it's called lucky fines
so but actually it's not a book it's a
bunch of cards
and if you
and when i teach in in the classroom
with kids
i lay all this out on the floor and the
kids absolutely love it you know i just
spread all the cards out on the floor
and they're
you know they're just
i mean things are this way in that way
and i hand drew those letters that you
see there what is that there's another
one there's another one
i'm just curious what what are some of
like if you chose one last they're
different letters
so
yeah they're hand drawn okay i draw them
and sometimes the writing is upside down
and sideways i'll do a different font
but each piece is kind of a
um
it hangs together in a way but it's up
to the reader to figure it out
something like that but when i show this
to kids in school
we spread all the cards out on the floor
and then they make their own
and they get
they just love it they they absolutely
love it
um
see on this one you got to read it this
way then you got to turn it upside down
and read it that way
oh here's one where i just have a lot of
negative space and it just says
carbon cycle
illustrious and then there's those two
letters
so you know i play with
the forms
so it's not just like you're reading a
story or a poem it's all broken up
there
anyway there's 52 of them
and
it's called lucky fines because it's
like you
come across something on the pavement
and you pick it up and go oh a quarter
a lucky find
for a new writer should they try these
different tonalities or personalities or
just stay
in the beginning
with their authentic voice and then once
they have mastered that
then venture out to these other sort of
areas well
you know
as i said i'm kind of an old athlete and
i learned boxing and swimming and
football and
basketball and how to play golf
uh i always notice that when you're
being taught
you're being taught from the ground up
uh you you're being taught basic
movements and then you build on that for
instance when i was
boxing
um
i spent a long time not being allowed to
throw punches
everything had to be footwork
and i thought come on when do i get to
punch somebody
but
when you learn footwork
you discover that
a punch will have as much strength
not as your power here
but in your legs
and if you are balanced when you throw a
punch
and if you are
transferring the energy from the legs to
the body
you get more power
so everything depends on the legs and
and the stance
same with tennis when you're playing
tennis
if if your feet are too close together
or too far apart you don't have as much
balance or power
so one of the things you learn playing
tennis is you're learning to
run to where the ball is and then plant
your feet correctly before you swing
because if your feet are planted
correctly then the swing
you know if you learn how to do the
swing that would be the next thing uh
but you foundation is very important so
in my first class in method writing it's
all about the voice how to manipulate
the natural voice and yeah you practice
we we have exercises that you do from
week to week and
we work on that then when you go to my
advanced class
now we work on the four voices and again
you're practicing and at some point
uh we have an exercise where you get a
pair of dice
and you throw the dice and each number
corresponds to
one of the concepts you've learned up to
this point
so if a number two comes up and let's
say it's the
the fancy schmancy voice you've got to
write four lines of fancy schmancy
then you roll the dice again oh six
comes up what is that oh that's uh
straight talk well hey one you won't
believe what happened but it's all the
same piece it's a it's all a coherent
idea or story but you're switching every
four lines
and so everybody thinks oh it's not
going to make any sense but it ends up
making perfect sense because you're
changing tonalities
and it's the change of tonalities that
makes for drama
more than just the drama in the story
i don't know if you fully get that
the story isn't where the drama is the
drama is in the tonalities that you
switch
and great composers when they write they
don't just write the same note 100 times
they're changing
uh when when beethoven took my class
early on
he had written a symphony and he brought
it in and the opening of the symphony
went this way
[Music]
it's a little boring
you're doing nothing with the deep voice
why don't you do like the straight talk
voice you know where you you get high
like that and he said oh well i've got
to try that i better do that next week
and then he comes in next week and he
did the deep voice but then he switched
to that very light voice so now when you
listen to the fifth symphony it goes
[Music]
very good ludwig
you're getting the idea of tonal
dynamics you want to switch those tones
so when they do that dice thing
it surprises a lot of them they go wow
that really worked
the piece made sense
those changes in tone didn't give the
read a whiplash
it just felt like good writing
and good writing is tonal dynamics and
one of the reasons why a lot of people's
stories are boring is because the voice
is the same all the way
through
can we practice something
can can we yeah together can you give me
an assignment and all and then correct
me good night are you gonna write it or
you're gonna say i'll just probably say
it just maybe i don't know if i was in
the class okay and you were testing me
to say it i mean it's about writing but
okay uh i've given you the four voices
right plus writing like you talk right
so you got writing like you talk
you've got
that
that high voice that's a lot of
chit-chat stuff boy you won't believe
what happened and then man you know
knock me for a feather but i was there
you know
then there's the fancy voice
poetic
very lots of
images metaphors similes all that kind
of crap
and then there's that written song where
you take something and you repeat it
anything it doesn't matter whatever you
say you can repeat it three times
whatever you say you can say it twice
whatever you say you can say it louder
whatever you say you can say it softer
whatever you can say you can say it with
more feeling whatever you say you can
say it deadly knows any phrase is
repeatable you just have to repeat it
and then add the rest of the sentence
the rest of the sentence is what would
be different
see in a larger sense we cannot
what dedicate we cannot what consecrate
we cannot what hallow this ground so
that's the repetition and then uh the
last voice is total nonsense
now do you want to do it does that work
yeah you want to give me a topic i i
couldn't oh no we don't do topics you
don't do topics okay i'm sorry i don't
do whatever you don't do no we don't do
topics
i gotta call your manager here then so
you're just gonna in other words i'm i'm
gonna call out the voice
now what i want you to do is just to
talk
and if you talk eventually you'll
probably get into something you remember
or
something will come up don't worry about
it
so if you fail who cares you know
whatever right yeah okay however
i will say if i say
straight talk or if i say lost world
that's fancy schmancy
if i say red and sung
that's the repetitious voice
if i say absence of field meaning no
rhyme or reason just nonsense and if i
say like you talk
just talk like you talk
okay so you'll just start
blabbing about anything
are you ready i think so yeah okay ready
go
okay
noticing that food prices are going up a
lot it's things seem very expensive and
uh
i'm not quite sure why but um straight
talk it's it's really you're going into
the market and i'm noticing a dollar
increase in what i normally buy now
you're still talking like you talk you
got to get that high voice i went in the
market like god what am i crazy did i
get you know okay gotta go up there okay
so keep going straight talk so i'm at
the market the other day and there's
this woman and she's in my way and i'm
trying to get to the food and the stuff
is not on sale like i thought it was
supposed to be and then i say that
sorry that one is the repetition
repetition
the food that we eat
brings us life
but if life
brings us nothing but
bills and duty
and chores and errands and they
they don't take us anywhere lost world
fancy schmancy oh
um according to the gdp uh
let me know let me rephrase that it's
hard to do it with you
because we don't talk that way no no no
see
it's almost as if i'm writing a a letter
or something um
it has come to my attention that
food prices have escalated beyond the
normal day-to-day
more poetry
come on okay fancy schmancy
it has come to my attention that food
which is life
which is what sustains us which is what
gives us
a reason
to
be with our loved ones and and
break daily bread and and
love love one another and and come
together as community good but you're
not writing in that style you're still
talking like you talk okay it would have
to be poetic okay i thought it
was because
no no you were doing uh not goods
phrases okay but you could talk that way
okay so but you got to write poetically
and what's the one that's abstract
because life
because life streamed out like a rhythm
upon the cloistered hills of of
existence breaks however many stars that
fuel the clouds that break into the
heart and expose the truth of your own
soul rigid against tribulation striven
against death
broken open against life the platitudes
of existence and the small icicles that
form inside the caverns of your soul
break out of you you know that's
but that's lost world you've
got to be able to do that okay wow okay
and it's hard to do it when you're
talking see that's why this is about
writing it's not about talking so it's
harder for you to do that
but that's what you would have to shift
into
and then keep going
absence of field
and that is where i'm almost asked not
what your country can do for you no
you're making sense oh okay well okay um
so
food
life
love
death
honor
that's a field
because you're saying one word at a time
each one is different but that's a field
it it's a it's a logical progression
so
each unit
can't be the same as the one before or
else you're establishing a field
like an electrical field a gravitational
field this is no field so the words and
the phrases are like all jumbled up
but if you just do the same thing
that's a field
so you could do two of them but then the
third thing has got to be a phrase
then another phrase then something
doesn't you know you got to just keep
breaking sentence structure around you
have to practice these things they're
not as simple no this is difficult you
know very difficult
custom shaved nether of any kind of the
sofa retains black teeth of soft there
in the eyeballs of no one came
it father
hair broken nostril
the shiny light of the sea that
protrudes over the waves
here
nowhere
stream
captain broken arrow it's always in the
gut of
nothing was done he was a champion
see i'm just
that's absence of field
nothing can ever connect or converge
you can't have a field writing a
sentence is a field
subject verb object
preposition you know it's okay
sentences are fields this would be an
absence of field
math
gold
belly of the beast
golden wheat
air
something long now
because you've done a lot of short
things ask not what your country can do
for you good but don't finish the
sentence
ask not what your country can and then
stop
see
okay
but that's a technique that's been used
in writing in the 20th century by a lot
of writers including
james joyce this stream of consciousness
and you might do that if you were having
a character who was either having a
hallucination or they were demented
having dementia
or someone is falling and you're trying
to
what it's like to be falling what goes
through a person's mind
not in normal sentences but everything
is colliding because it's all happening
in five seconds as they're falling
so you could use the technique
to con someone's drowning you know you
would use absence of field for that
and so in in these four other tonalities
not the the
regular voice quote unquote
that
sharpens the the tool that that
strengthens the muscle how does that
help do you pay attention to how the
writer is working or do you just enjoy
the story depends depends on whether i'm
playing something or reading something
and there are other distractions going
on okay what about music
do you listen to any kind of classical
music at all yes i have well
have you ever listened to bruckner and
really paid attention to what bruckner
does compared to let's say brahms
bruckner is absence of field a lot
bruckner's got tonalities and changes
that are very mysterious and very
sublime whereas brahms has got these
melodies that roll over almost like to
be read and sung so if you pay attention
to writers and you pay attention to
composers and you pay attention to
almost any kind of art picasso
any painter you will see that they do
different things all the time
yeah they might have their basic
i'll say writing in their own voice uh
approach but they use all these other
techniques the next time you read a book
you know a good novel i promise you
you're going to see writing like you in
your own voice you're going to see
lost world which is poetic
you know fancy description or something
you're going to see red and sun once in
a while look charles dickens opens up
tale of two cities with was the best of
times it was the worst of times it was
the season of this was the winter of
discontent you're going to see
repetition
you're also going to see
absence of field sometime where the work
is very uh stream of consciousness
whether it's james joyce or virginia
woolf or tony morrison or writers who do
that you're going to see it but you
can't be reading for pleasure you have
to be reading like you're paying
attention
i know how to drive a car i would have
no idea how to fix the engine but a
mechanic he understands how the engine
works and when people look at writing
most people they don't look under the
hood to see what's going on they just
learn how to drive and turn the wheel
and start and stop and go fast and go
slow
but a writer if you study writing that
question you asked ask me karen you will
go oh
look he just went from writing like you
talk to fancy schmancy
oh look he just went from fancy schmancy
to
straight talk
holden caulfield catcher in the rye does
it all the time so you will see those
four tones and
the tone of writing in your own voice
you will see that being done just the
way beethoven went
uh
you will see these changes of tone of
tonality of dynamic that's why i call it
tonal dynamics because it's dynamic it
changes
so you're going to see it in literature
all over the place
so was the first part of becoming a
better writer to pay attention
not just to your own writing to other
works of art not even not even
literature but
music
there's no great writer that hasn't paid
attention to almost every writer that
came before them going all the way back
to gilgamesh the iliad the odyssey
augustine's confessions
catullus's poems in the first century bc
uh you know dante they they know it all
and they don't just read
for pleasure they read
like a writer they read like an artist
they pay attention they study oh look
what he's doing look what he's doing and
then they copy it a little bit and then
they extend it even further
you know
artists are always influenced by the
artists who came before them and then
they
go one better so
yeah
whatever you do whether you're a
sculptor or a painter or a writer or a
composer
um
yeah you've got to study the people who
came before you and see what they're
doing
because it's it's a conversation
artists are talking to each other across
the millennia they're talking
and you want to see what the
conversation is you want to know what
dante said to shakespeare and what
shakespeare said to
homer and what homer said to
uh
phillip roth
or ann sexton you know what are they
saying not
in the met
in the message but in the technique
in the technique
oh oh look what braum look what the
bruckner did look at the way he extended
that chord and did a variation that was
interesting that was different from
anything beethoven did
oh look what mahler did
look how he did that you study it
any composer you ask them man they've
studied them all
so being conscious and you want to see
absence of field check out elliot carter
oldest
he might be dead by now but he was in
his hundreds 100 the last time i heard
he wrote a string quartet just recently
listen to beethoven's last
six string quartets
a lot of that is absence of field as a
matter of fact
if you listen to beethoven's um
piano sonata
110 or 111 i can't remember which one it
is
i was listening to it one day and
there's like a
four bar section in there that
if you hear it you if you're listening
you'll hear it
it's jazz
where he got it i don't know
i mean boom but if you listen but
all of a sudden it's jazz and then it
goes back
to the normal kind of progressions that
they did in beethoven's time um
so his string quartets his late piano
concertos you're going to hear a lot of
stuff and you're going to go
well where'd that come from how did he
do that
because as an artist you always want to
see not what did they do but how did
they do it
how did they create that
it's not about the plot or the story
it's about the technique
how did they do that how did they do
that
how does a writer know they have written
something in their true voice i think
you
you know you you know what what
true writing is you know you know what
it is
i mean i know when i'm bullshitting
how do you know
you just know i i know it
actors know it even in the middle of
doing it
actors can be in the middle of a play
and at some moment they can go oh i'm
bullshitting
and then
actors have techniques to get them back
grounded
they look at the other actor they
connect with their being as opposed to
acting so
you know when you're bullshitting
now with writing it's not about whether
you're not being true it's about are you
writing sentences that you wouldn't
speak
that's the difference between writing in
your own voice
and writing in those other four tones
that are not a natural voice red and
sung lost world to be a
straight talk and absence of field those
are not natural voices those are
literary
you you wouldn't write like that were it
not for the fact that we live in a
post-literate era
age
i mean you read books
so you have learned from school how to
write
like a writer you you write that way all
the time you use prepositional phrases
and
participle clauses
because it's writing you you put in
adjectives and adverbs like you bought a
stamp collecting kit full of them and
you're using them you wouldn't do that
if it weren't not for writing
if this was a pre-literate society
everything you write would be like you
talk
because there would be no other way to
write but once you start developing
these
techniques or styles
then you learn that in school and you
mimic that when you write and when you
want to be a writer you throw in
adjectives and adverbs and fancy verbs
you don't say he said you say he
responded
when was the last time you were talking
to someone and saying yeah and i came
home and uh i asked my brother what he
was doing and he responded by saying but
no you never do that you say i said you
know where did you go last night and he
said well i stayed out and i said the
whole night and he said yeah the whole
night and i said you know you're going
to get in trouble with mom and dad and
he said that's how we talk we don't go
he responded and then i murmured and
then i averred and then i retorted you
you learned that in school
you wouldn't write that way unless you
learned it
in school from writing
so
you attune yourself to the difference
between writing like you talk and
writing in a literary way just like a
a musician knows when they hit a flat or
sharp note
they hear it
so if i'm okay i'm sorry you can hear it
if i'm writing and i know that
not that it's garbage but it's it's not
true it's not authentic it's bs as as to
what you said earlier okay
could you
what do you mean by true
well that's what i'm trying to determine
well but writing and something being
true are two different things okay i can
lie
but i can do it in an authentic voice
how is that
we do it all the time
we make up stories we lie well all of a
sudden we lie we start doing it like a
writer
if we did that everybody would know
we're lying
sometimes we lie better than when we
look the truth is just the
facts saying the truth
like you talk is the issue
lying like you talk is the issue
ask me to make something up okay
um let's suppose you're an attorney and
you're presenting your client's case
and maybe you know your client's guilty
but this is your job to defend the
person the person's uh may be involved
in a ponzi scheme
and maybe
they had kids to support and their back
was against the wall and they had to do
what they had to do and it's your duty
to defend this person and which one of
those sentences you just said are not
like you talk
it's your duty to defend this person
i don't think i would say that you
wouldn't say what it's your duty to
defend this person you wouldn't say that
i don't think so you just said it right
but i don't think i would say it in my
real voice that is you that's your
sentence okay you're not talking like a
writer you're talking like a person a
poison okay
you're writing like a joke
okay so then help me out here so because
we're doing like a little bit of a yeah
okay okay so so then
is that my authentic voice you can't
talk
like a writer
you don't know how to do that
but you know how to write like a writer
because they're two different things
and it's very hard for someone who
thinks that writing fancy is how they
talk to say to them no don't do that you
wouldn't use that adjective there you
wouldn't use that adverb there if you
were just talking
then people have to just like with
acting sometimes people are overacting
and they don't even know it oh they
think they're great but they're
overacting you can smell it a mile away
so you have to develop what hemingway
called the detector where you
can know
when you're writing an authentic
sentence this doesn't mean it's true it
could be a lie
that's not the issue
the issue is are you writing are you
acting true
look if if i'm gonna be hannibal lecter
i don't need people's flesh
but i gotta act like i do
so it isn't about what the story is
about it's about my ability as an actor
to look real
whether i'm talking about eating flesh
or talking about eating a rib eye steak
i still got to be talking
and performing
like what i'm doing is true so when i
write something that's a lie i still got
to write it in in my natural voice and
if i don't i should know how to do that
and do it on purpose
but that's writing it's very hard for
people to talk
like
in poetic form or it's very hard we're
not we're not trained that way uh gore
vidal and maybe william buckley could do
it you know they could uh
pontificate
uh
the american economy such as it was
labeled during the time of lincoln when
uh unbeknownst to both of them the
forces of capitalism had somehow merged
with socialism had therefore even though
uh people were not aware of it cattle
catapulized itself in such a way that
the proclivities of those who traded in
the market have scunded with whatever
kinds of um
dough we might say that they could lay
their hands on if you know what i mean
see that's william buckley nobody talks
that way
that's buckley or gorby dahl they know
how to speak like that if i'm a defense
lawyer in front of a jury
i'm going to talk
naturally i'm not going to talk like a
professor of english
but if i had to talk that unnaturally i
probably would write it and memorize it
because it wouldn't come naturally to me
unless as a defense attorney i did it a
lot
ladies and gentlemen of the jury
on a wind-swept night when my client
unbeknownst to the proclivities of his
own heart trampled across the snow
covered lawn of the murdered victim he
didn't know
realize or even
perceive
that life
thread
moved stretched to the very end of its
core had somehow in the being and
nothingness of time
caused him to freeze and be unable to
pick up the ax frozen standard held up
against the light of the sun and smash
it against the victim's head no
ladies and gentlemen of the jury he did
not have the
intestinal fortitude to advance
step by inch and step by foot into the
den
of the victim's own criminal activities
see that's not how you talk
that's a lot of
but it doesn't have to be
true or a lie that's separate from how i
say it
how i write it
you either write the way a person talks
or you write in a literary style
and you have to know the difference
between the two and you have to know
when to do one and when to do the other
just like a good actor sometimes knows
when to act
sometimes you have to
act you're being natural and then all of
a sudden you take a line you go
i'm gonna do this like shakespeare
now have you ever seen the movie um
i think it's called network
do you know
do you know the scene
do you know the scene where um it's in
the newsroom he brings him into that
room uh mr beale and he tells him that
what he's doing he can't do anymore
because he's really upsetting the whole
business structure of of television and
money and all that stuff so they go into
that room
where there's a long table and there's
those green lights that they use in
board rooms
and he brings them in and he sits him
down at one end of the ring and then he
goes to the other end
and then the lines he has is mr beale
you have tampered with the forces of
nature
okay
now
ed beatty
a decision
i'm going to say this line like you
might say it in shakespeare
not the way a person would talk
now the line is written as it's written
but an actor has to interpret it that's
different from a writer writing
something in a forced literary way so
here's an actor who's being natural and
then suddenly he becomes very
uh shakespearean
now
i will do the scene for you uh he says
um uh mr beal um
i haven't seen do you would you like a
glass of water uh okay i just just
couple things i want to go over with you
you walk through
uh mr beale
you
have tampered with the forces of nature
you see mr beal the economy is a small
thing that does that and when you tell
people to see so he switched from
talking in a natural voice to a kind of
a shakespearean big kind of thing well
writers can do that too they can be
writing in a natural
sentence structure and then they can
shift into something poetic and it might
only be for one sentence
because they want to kind of
give something extra to the moment and
they know how to do that
so the acting analogy i gave you it's an
acting analogy the writing analysis
would be
speaking in a normal way and then all of
a sudden you're getting very poetic and
then
writing it that way and you have to know
the difference
you know and as hemingway said you have
a built-in
detector that can tell
when you're doing it
inadvertently
if you do it you want to do it on
purpose
and you want to know how to write in
that fancy style and you want to know
how to write in a very simple way
when faultsteph
in henry iv part 2
sees prince hal who's now the king
and when
king henry iv was just the prince and he
hung out with falstaff who's a rogue and
a thief and a
big buffoonish comic character
once he becomes king falstaff
is so excited he tells all his minions
now that he's king he's going to call me
into the castle and i'm going to have a
job and i'm going to make a lot of money
and
and false if he's thinking how he's
going to be able to steal money and all
that sort of stuff
and then the scene comes where the
coronation comes and hal is walking down
you know with the the coronation and
falstaff is in the crowd and he rushes
out
and he says how my boy my prince
and he was expecting hal to look at him
and say falstaff
come you know the whole thing but hal is
now king
and how as king henry iv
must renounce
everything that falstaff stood for
to be a good king that's what
shakespeare was writing about what what
does it take to be a good king
you've got to be a man of the people but
you also have to know how to be a king
so falseth says and falstaff is the
richest
probably the most loved character in all
of shakespeare because he's funny and
he's very human
and we see how he's full of
so we we love him yeah great actors play
falstaff
uh he goes
prince my boy
and he opens his arms
and hal looks at him and he says
i know thee not old man
fall to thy knees presume not that i am
the thing that i was
that is pretty powerful
and except for the the
it's writing like you talk you talk
about shakespeare
i know thee not old man
presume not i am the thing i was fall to
your knees
it's writing like you talk
and shakespeare knows how to write like
you talk
and he also knows how to write
poetically and if you go through
shakespeare's plays you can see the
differences and the changes
even
with absence of field when king lear is
on the heath going mad
blow winds crack your cheeks you know he
goes crazy some of that speech
is
nonsense it makes no sense because king
lear is losing his mind
he's going crazy
and
shakespeare uses a little bit of absence
of feel there so all these techniques
are used by writers
but if you didn't know to look for them
you wouldn't notice them
but if you know what you're looking for
you will notice them
even straight talk
when would you say all of a sudden well
anyway
we do that when we talk all the time
yeah
yeah you know when i was 19 my father
died and
i had to come home and we had to bury
him
anyway so how have you been what's
what's going on i mean hey tell me a
little bit of something about your life
you know i haven't seen you in 20 years
we we do that in life we can be
deep and
authentic and then all of a sudden we
start talking with that jibber jab away
well
to be a not to be that is a question
whether it's just nobler in the mind to
suffer the slings and arrows of
outrageous fortune or to take arms
against your sea of troubles and by
opposing in them to die
to sleep
perchance the dream
hi there's the rub
that's straight talk all right there ah
there's there's the trick you know you
start doing that and the next thing you
know you're riding your ass
that's basically what shakespeare does
here all right there's the rub and why
does he do it he does it because he
knows that if you don't have changes of
tone it gets boring
boring
so to die
to sleep
perchance the dream
all right there's the rub for in the
sleep of death what dreams may come when
we have shuffled off this mortal coil
must give us pause
cause there's the rub
and then he starts getting deep again
and he starts getting deep again and he
does straight talk a little bit later on
when he figures out uh
you know how he's going to get the king
so shakespeare does that all the time
little switches he goes from writing
like you talk to the deep
well the the the lost world voice that
fancy voice man he can do poetic stuff
like like he was born doing that and he
will go to straight talk and sometimes
even absence of field when he's got a
character who's just spouting out
nonsense for because they're going mad
or because they are a con man
you know maybe they're a con man and
they're kind of flummoxing you with uh
jibber-jabber
shakespeare does all that and he knows
he's doing it
go ahead thank you guys we'll just wait
my glasses yeah
and then here's a good joke i'll show
you you ready uh-huh
oh excuse me oops
i do that
i'm doing that for my students because
they do that in class all the time you
know i'll be going well um you know
look excuse me
see that's tonal dynamics too
you know when when
when you're pontificating sometimes you
gotta know when to change the tone or
else people get bored
sometimes i do it too late they're
already bored but
you know you you want to change the tone
a little bit comic relief
yeah and a defense attorney to a jury
would a good one would know to do that
what is a writer's deep voice and is
there more than one inside of a writer
at any time you're talking about
characters
right deep voice well there's only one
deep voice there's only one okay yes a
deep voice
now i could be the deep voice of
one character i could be the voice of
another and there might be a difference
in the character and how it would
manifest but the deep voice means you're
coming from the deep gut
you're not you know you're you're
connected
but we're not this isn't deep throat in
in in calling in a tip to woodward and
bernstein this is a real
person inside this is this is who you
are what you really feel this isn't you
pontificating i'm confused i'm sorry i
don't know what deep voice means
um
it's talking in a way in which you're
not
entertaining anymore you're
you're just coming from what you feel in
a deep deep way and you're not trying to
be a writer you're not trying to perform
you're you're just
connected when you're not in a deep
voice you're telling a story and you're
entertaining
it was a cold night and a man walked out
you know you're trying to entertain
people but when you're in the deep voice
you are
connected
in a true way to an emotion
you're connected to an emotion
so
you're not just telling the story like a
storyteller you're connected to an
emotion now you may not do that for the
whole story because there are parts of
the story that might have to be
a tonal dynamic with a little lost world
a little straight talk a little written
song
but when you're in the deep voice
it's like that um commercial
with uh the guy about uh
uh when ef hutton talks everybody
listens
you know
when you hear the deep voice you listen
you could be in a crowded restaurant and
everybody's talking and then someone at
the next table starts to whisper and
suddenly your ear catches it you don't
know what they're saying but you hear
the tone of voice
and you go oh this is going to be
personal
this is going to be deep and emotional
this is not just going to be him telling
a story about how he spilled water on
himself you know it's going to be deep
so when you
were here in front of us just maybe i
don't know 45 minutes ago and you were
telling us about the call that you got
at 19
that was your deep voice
well i was reliving it in a way that it
was emotionally coming into me and
i wasn't thinking of
how do i write this or anything i was
just feeling it
when you're feeling something very
authentically you're in a true place
can you fake it sure
as a writer as an actor
you learn where that comes from and you
can
go there
you can do it technically it's a it's a
technical thing
coming from an emotion
is technical if you can do it
where you really feel the emotion
that's better better because then you
don't have to act
but if you're a good actor you can find
a way to feel the emotion
and then you're there
some actors have to have a different
memory to help them do that
when
in apocalypse now when martin sheen
was doing something in the film he
imagined the death of his own father
that would make him get very emotional
it wasn't in the scene but that's what
he played inside his imagination which
allowed him to get an authentic feeling
it wasn't the same as in the film but
you didn't know that you don't know what
the actor's thinking
they once asked clark cable
when you tell a woman you love her in a
movie how do you say that with so much
feeling
and he said well i just imagine they're
a big porterhouse steak
so an actor will
maybe
find
an emotional memory to help them get
that memory other actors know how to
technically do it just to
connect to their deep voice
and the same is in writing when you're
writing
you
you should know when you're writing from
your deep voice and when you're just
telling a story
and he had a heart attack on the set of
apocalypse now didn't he
uh who
didn't she have a a heart attack yeah so
i mean he's still alive oh yes he's
thriving yeah yeah he's on shows and
other films but but i wonder i don't
know what the circumstances were but if
he was imagining that
death of his own father
how how
how
maybe maybe it was so real it was so
authentic
i don't know sometimes actors do
feel something that's so real
um you know they find a way to
personalize it if they need to
sometimes you don't have to because
you're acting and it's you're believing
what you're doing
but sometimes you you can't so you
you're really thinking
something else in your mind to get the
emotion out uh well sometimes an actor
will do something that's so
heavy
that when the director says cut they're
still in that emotion so
i'm not disputing whether he had a heart
attack or not maybe he did
i guess
acting can be dangerous
you got to be careful
don't play any parts that might cause
you to have a heart attack
i think i'll just play peter pan
well that would have its own you might
have to be too
too up and happy and then
yeah you're right you see so that i
don't know if that would be safe art is
art is fraught there's an interesting
rhyme art and fraud
art is fraught with danger
i like that yeah you should yeah that's
your next book let's see
first there's there's dante
abandon hope all ye who enter that be
one the second would be
call me ishmael and the third would be
art is fraught with danger jack greeks
it's good to remember you know all of us
who are writers or actors or filmmakers
or whatever we should write that and put
it you know in our room to remind us
art is fraught with danger
it'd be good good thing to remember is
that a personal mission statement no i
just said it and i said it and i thought
oh that's fun
should a writer have their own personal
mission statement
um you mean if we asked writers if they
had a mission statement would they have
one maybe it's not even in full
if fully fleshed out there's just
something in them they know their own
abilities yeah they probably do
i don't have to make one up because i
i know what socrates said and that to me
is good enough
he said
know thyself
and then he said the unexamined life
is not worth living
so those are two pretty good mission
statements wouldn't you say the
unexamined life is not worth living and
know thyself
do people still live an unexamined life
in this day and age well we all to some
extent i mean
if i examined my life totally i'd be
writhing on the floor
in agony
but you know i think you can
uh
you know i've i've been in therapy i
think a lot of people have had therapy
or they've read books on spirituality or
uh
whatever you know gone on retreats and
meditations and whatnot
and i'm sure people have examined their
life to some extent of course
i think you said though that good art is
not about
um and forgive me uh it was it was
something you said about good art is not
about
you know kind of like getting all your
issues out it's also about making the
viewer feel something and forgive me i
i'm
no it's that's true you you
you know you're building a chair so
people can sit in it
i mean i can be as creative as i want
about making a chair
uh i know my wife got a chair the other
day that she really liked and
and we sat in it you know she looked
great she loved the way it looked and
said i'm going to put that in my office
and blah blah blah and one day i sat and
i went boy this chair is really
uncomfortable
so
the artist
on some level they're making something
that they hope will touch or astound or
shock
uh the the viewer
i mean on one level you're doing it for
yourself
you're you're exploring your own
technical materials if you're a painter
if you're a writer you're a sculptor
a
good
friend of mine who's a poet in a
sculptures
she began experimenting with cardboard
and made the most amazing things but a
lot of times she's just exploring
the materials
what if i do this with the cardboard and
i bend it this way and i glue it this
way you you're experimenting with the
material same with the writer
and other times perhaps you do care
about what the viewer will think or get
from it if you write a story or a poem
or something you're
you're saying
okay uh
what i wrote you know i'm
it came out of me but
it could be clearer
uh i'm i don't think
my reader's gonna get it a hundred
percent so what do i need to add or cut
to make it work better
because a piece of writing works it's a
piece of writing it's like a machine
it works you know you get a machine from
the hardware store and you plug it in
and it doesn't work you take it back
it might look good
all the parts are put together the right
way but something's wrong it's not
working
and that you bring they go oh
there's a washer here that needs to be
put here ah well same thing with a piece
of writing or a poem i'll go oh that
image there is not clear if the image is
not clear then there's no payoff at the
end
but so i've got to make that image clear
and then the reader will get it when i
get to the end so you're you're trying
to figure out whether it's a novel or a
story or a poem
or play or screenplay whatever
is it working
here in this spot
so when you edit you're not always just
correcting grammar and punctuation
you're you're thinking of it as
a device that has to
do something to the viewer or the reader
so hmm something's not working here
what is it what do i have to do
do i have to cut something add something
maybe move this over here oh
sometime when someone reads a poem in my
class
i will say to them read it backwards
not word for word but line for line
and it works better backwards because
when we write we either i mean it can
work either way
we go from
an idea to something specific
or we start with some something specific
and as we develop the poem we come into
possession of a big idea
and sometimes it works better when you
go from the
idea to the specific and sometimes it
works better when you go from the
specific to an idea
so someone will read something to me and
i'll go oh okay they they started with
an idea and then they got specific if
they flip it
then the reader will get the
specific first
and then as the poet comes into
possession of the idea
it will make more sense
well
that's a kind of uh simplified version
of that but
when you're writing
you you you're thinking does this work
it's it's a machine it's a it's a it's
an object you know you put a quarter in
and it should do it what it's supposed
to do and when it doesn't you fiddle
with it you think of how do i make this
work better
and um
you know there's an old saying writing
is rewriting
so
first drafts are usually
that's all their first drafts
i've never written anything
that didn't go through more than one
draft
i in other words i've never written
anything that was perfect
the first time out
now you're supposed to ask me why
well okay i was actually thinking about
you said the scene the ending scene of
saving private ryan
was very emotional too yeah
so
do you think that that scene
meant different things to different
people
well you you can't
know
how something is going to affect someone
uh people can be affected by something a
hundred different ways
all you can do as an artist or a writer
is to
make a good guess
and say in order for this scene to work
the line has to be different
or i need to put the line over here or i
need to cut the line and say it
this way you can only guess you can only
imagine you know
and and ultimately you are satisfying
yourself you're saying this works for me
so hopefully it'll work for others
now with the first draft you'd said
something previously i said that i've
never written
uh a perfect first draft well there was
also something you said in another and
you were supposed to say okay but that's
not what i'm actually going to say
though so what i'm going to say is but i
will give you the answer if you don't
ask the question how about i ask the
question afterwards you can ask it at
any time let me ask the question about
genius you had talked about genius i
know what you're referring to oh you do
okay yeah what is it i talk about the
accidents of genius yes thank you right
um
everyone has genius in them
they just don't know what it is
what they do know is their talent
and your talent will never produce
anything great
it will only produce something that's
good
your genius is what is capable
of creating something great
but because we rely on our talent
we often never get to our genius because
talent is the obstacle to genius
it's when you don't know what you're
doing sometime it's when you are falling
and you are
you're just at the mercy of the gods
that your genius wakes up and says
this looks like a job for genius man and
genius comes through
and you do something and it's amazing
and what do you think of the two things
someone says when whether it's a
painting or a story or a poem or
whatever
when they get something that's utterly
amazing what do you think of the two
things they say to themselves
it's crap
they they know it's great oh i see them
what do you think they say to themselves
i'm a genius i'm amazing no that's not
what they say okay
have you ever had that experience where
you did something and you go oh
i thought just a minute ago yeah yeah
okay
what do you what do you say to yourself
i thought i was going to ask a brilliant
question and then i realized that it
wasn't
no you asked a different question sure i
wanted you to ask the question why okay
that's all i mean i've
done things where i thought it was
amazing and it and it didn't get that
reception and then vice versa but when
you knew it was amazing what was the
first thing you said
to yourself
uh that it's powerful
yeah but
okay
i mean you know i'm sorry my in my
elementary world i'm gonna say it i'm
gonna say it and you're gonna go oh of
course you're right okay
you write something or you do something
as an actor maybe in the middle of a
scene and afterwards you go oh my god
that was amazing
and then you say to yourself
where did that come from
oh okay yes
because you don't know where it came
from correct all the other stuff you did
you know it came from your talent you
know that you know how to do that stuff
but this thing
you go where did that come from
then what's the next thing you ask
yourself how can i do that again exactly
oh yeah i gotta write how how can i do
that again right and the point is there
is no formula for that
otherwise people would be accessing
their genius constantly but they're not
they're they usually depending on their
talent which is uh understandable that's
okay
but
talent will only get what's good
genius
will get what's great but
your talent
is your biggest obstacle
and when you let go of your talent
sometime and are willing to fail because
you have no idea what you're doing
sometimes your genius comes to the
rescue and when it does you do something
and it shocks you and your first thought
is
how did i do that
and your second thought is
how can i do it again
because you want to do it again
but you can't make it happen you can
only be receptive to it happening you
can only be available
for it happening and how do you make
yourself available and receptive
by getting rid of your talent and if you
think that's easy you have another
thought coming because you and your
talent are in cahoots
you say to your talent make me look good
and i'll keep you on the payroll and
your talent says
keep me on the payroll and i'll make you
look good so the two of you got a deal
going here
you're both gonna make
the artist look
good but that's not what you want what
you want is something great
and it's always unexpected and it's
always an accident of your genius and
the accident happens when you're falling
off a cliff and all of a sudden you fly
you wouldn't fly if you were on on earth
you can't make it happen but you're
falling you're in the unknown you don't
know what to do
and you've got to do something because
the moment is presenting itself and when
it does you write something or you do
something with your
paintbrush or something or sculpting you
put this here and you go
how did i do that
how can i do it again
so
that's the
the relationship between
genius and talent
and guess what
i went to a chinese restaurant one night
and i got a fortune cookie cracked it
open and you know what it said i've kept
it all these years
it said
talent does what it can
genius does what it must
i like that and i want that's it
talent does what it can it's limited it
does what it can but genius does what it
has to do because you're in trouble
you're falling off a cliff you've come
to a point in your art where you have no
idea what to do next and you blunder
into something and you go
where'd that come from
how do i do that again
and is that where people get themselves
in trouble is they think that they can
duplicate that over and over again well
i don't know what you know gets
themselves in trouble i mean
look
yeah the whole idea of
creating art is to get yourself in
trouble as much as you can
but
and in acting too my my acting teacher
always used to say
put yourself in danger
he said that not not not get yourself in
trouble he said put yourself in danger
what he meant was be in a place where
your character is in danger and things
will happen
um
you know none of us want to be in
trouble we do the best we can and
we will rely on our talent the more
talented you are the more you will rely
on your talent
the less talented you are the more
likely you are to have
creative accidents because you have
nothing to rely on you have no idea what
the hell you're doing and sometimes you
know the amateur
you know wins at poker the first night
because they you don't know what you're
doing so that can happen but if you're
going to do it long enough at some point
you can't say i'm an amateur anymore you
have to say look i know what i'm doing i
have some talent i know i'm going to
rely on it sometime
but if i can once in a while get rid of
my talent my hopefully my hopefully
because if your genius came up every
time you got rid of your talent then it
would be simple it's the accidents of
your genius and when it doesn't come up
what happens
you you create
i'm a failure uh
not i'm a failure
i've
this failed right now
and that's how i get better by failing
my attitude toward failure is this
doesn't define who i am just because i
drop the ball when i'm juggling doesn't
mean
i'm not a good juggle i can i can be a
good juggler i just have to keep doing
it
so how i interpret the failure is
different from the willingness to have
that happen
when you take a risk and
most of the time when you take a risk
genius doesn't come see that's that's
the point
it's an accident of your genius it
doesn't always come but are you willing
to
lose a few times to get something great
because when they give you the nobel
prize karen they are not going to take
it away because someone went back to
your home and rooted through your trash
can and found that you wrote 100 poems
that were
they're not going to take it away
that's what every artist does they write
they write crap they fail it happens all
the time they're willing to take chances
so no one's going to take it away from
you when you win the nobel prize
but
you got to be willing to fail and when
you do
it may not end up being great
but you got to keep at it because
when you're willing to face that unknown
when you put yourself in danger and not
knowing where you're going and you risk
failure
sometimes
the accident of your genius comes up
it's like a
mushroom shaped cloud
[Laughter]
so anyway i you know
i've said this to my students and
they're always surprised because
everyone has this notion
that sometimes you just
write something and it's
perfect as soon as you write it it
happens
everyone assumes that happens that
everybody gets lucky sometime and i said
to them i have never written
something in a first draft that was
perfect
that never had to have any changes
and what do they say to that no you will
say why is that oh that's right okay
sorry whose line is it um
why do they say that
no why is that oh sorry okay let me try
that again
why is that this is funny this is a j
this is a funny joke
uh the way you
okay
um let me try sorry let's
why is that well wait no listen
a little digression here okay so you're
going to interview me okay okay yeah and
uh make sure you speak loud so they can
hear you sure you have to say
i understand you're the world's greatest
comedian
okay uh mr grapes i understand that you
are the world's greatest comedian
and i say yes
then you say to what do you attribute
your great success let me hear it to
what do you do
sorry you're going to say yes or no to
what do you attribute right but you're
going to say right yeah yes okay to what
do you attribute your great success good
let's just rehearse that one let's do it
and then we'll do it for the camera okay
okay all right uh start okay
you are the world's greatest comedian mr
graves no it's i understand oh okay
you got to get the lines exactly right
sure mr grapes mr grapes thank you for
taking my question uh karen with film
courage i understand you are the world's
greatest comedian yes okay to
to what do you attribute that successor
no to what do you attribute your great
success okay to what do you
to what do you attribute your great
success sir great are you are you ready
to shoot it oh i thought we already were
no we we were rehearsing right now okay
okay sorry no i mean i know he's running
it but right right okay this is the joke
okay sure sure so have you got it down
have you got your line yeah i think so i
think so okay okay um mr graves thank
you for taking my question karen with
film courage
i understand you're the world's greatest
comedian yes
to what do you timing
okay
there you go
you get it i do yeah okay
so
um
um i'm gonna say
i've never written a first draft that
was perfect and you're gonna say
why okay and then i'll give you the
answer sure that i give my students okay
i've never written a first draft that
was perfect
why
because i'm too good for that
okay now what does that mean
oh
many that's the thing because they're
not expecting that they think that if
you write a first draft it means you're
good and i said i never get a perfect
first draft because i'm too good for
that
that flips it on its head they're going
too good you mean if you're too good
all your first drafts are not good i
would think that if you're good your
first some of your first drafts might be
really good but you're saying
i'm too good to have a perfect first
draft
why do you think that would be
oh um
modesty
nope i just said i'm too good for that
okay
um
delusion
what delusion
the the what delusion delusional no no
i i i wrote it and i go this is not
perfect and i've never had a perfect
first drive i see um i don't know
because
i can see
where it can be improved
and the person who's not that good
doesn't see where it can be improved
but i'm good
i'm too good
to have a perfect first draft because i
can see
where it can be better
that's half the answer
the other half of the answer is
and i know how to make it better
because sometimes you can go
um this first draft it's
not quite
perfect i know it needs to be fixed but
i don't know how
what i'm saying is i'm too good for that
because one i can always see how
anything can be made better and two i
know how to do it
so that dispels that notion that a lot
of people have that if you really know
what you're doing you should be able to
write that first draft and it's perfect
and i'm saying
well
no
because if you're really good you will
always see how something can be made
better and
you have the tools
and the knowledge to make it better you
know how to do it
so again that to me is a little paradox
which i kind of like because hopefully
what i'm saying to my students is
don't
think
that the first draft of anything you
write is going to be perfect
because if you are really good
you will see that it can be better
and
if you know how to make it better that's
that's that's
that's what you want you want to be able
to go hmm this thing is not perfect but
if i do this this this and this
it'll be perfect
and so at what point does someone know
where the weaknesses are
at what point do they know where the
weaknesses are or at what point do they
get to where they go
well it's not perfect but
i'm done the latter
there's a famous saying that poets never
finish writing a poem they only abandon
it
that at some point you might still feel
well it's not perfect but
enough is enough i got to move on to my
next one you know so
maybe there's always going to be a point
where you think well this is as good as
i can make it and you you go on
i mean
i don't think you can say to someone
uh
there's a point where you will always
know where you can make it better and i
mean you know we're human beings
sometimes what we send out is imperfect
and
sometimes we got to go well
that's enough you know i got to move on
to the next thing
this is not the best soup i ever made
but it'll do
what is a transformational line
it's a sentence with eye in it that you
then massage to go deeper
can we
have an example
yeah say something with i in it okay
um
i've been really thinking about my life
okay so
about my life is what we call the
birthday cake get rid of that okay so
now you're left with i've been really
thinking okay okay now
what's the deeper truth
what's the the answer to the question
what is the story of my life and what is
the truth of who i am
the answer to that is i've been really
thinking
okay so
have you grocked that
what is the story of your life and what
is the truth of who you are i've been
really thinking
sure have you have you got that i've
been really thinking okay now don't
forget there's another concept see
there's a lot of stuff that goes to
demonstrate this
it's called the other side of the same
coin
and the other side of the same coin is
not the opposite it's the same thing
said from the other end
so if i say
i'm always late for work
the other side of the coin would be i'm
never early
if i say i take my time when i go to
work the other side of the coin would be
well i never take my time when i go to
i always give
i never take i always give
same thing from the other side
so what is the other side of the coin to
i've been really thinking
what's the other side
of the same coin
i don't know
well let's look at the word thinking
what does thinking imply that you're not
doing
i've been examining things what i've
been examining things no that's the same
idea okay what does it imply that you're
not doing
if you're always thinking what are you
not doing i'm not living i'm not living
so
um i've been thinking about something in
my life get rid of something about my
life that's birthday cake i've been
really thinking other side of the coin
is i've not been
really living
okay
okay okay so say those two lines
i've not been really living no i've
i've been really thinking
i've not been really living
i've been really thinking i've not been
really living
and what's the deeper truth underneath
that
karen
trying to think the deeper truth that
you've not been living there's a deeper
truth
well we've been in a pandemic
what we've been in a pandemic now you're
talking about something specific okay
and you're not giving me an eye it's got
to be an eye statement
i've been dealing with the pandemic
every day for the last year
so the fact that you've not been living
the deeper truth is not that it's a
pandemic it's about you
what's the deeper truth that you are not
really living
i haven't been going out anywhere okay i
haven't been going out that's good i'll
take that okay movie theaters but don't
think about the pandemic because then
then you're getting back to birthday
cakes okay okay i don't want you to do
birthday cakes it's the story of my life
and the truth of who i am not about a
pandemic
it's the truth of who you are the truth
of who you are is i've been really
thinking
i've not been really living
right what's the deeper truth
i'm confused i'm confused
what's the deeper truth to the fact that
karen is confused i found out some
information
that my life wasn't what i had been told
it was
say that again without i found that
information
i was told my life wasn't what it really
was
now get rid of i told myself and just
make the statement my life wasn't what
it really was
good
what's the deeper truth to that
then who was i
don't ask a question okay it's gotta be
i
make a statement
i didn't i'm not who i thought i was i'm
not who i thought i was deeper truth
i'm confused
that was earlier we're going deeper well
um
i'm confused
i'm not really who i thought i was
what's the deeper truth
how do we really know who we are i don't
i don't ask a question
oh i don't know who i really am now
and the deeper truth to that you don't
know who you really are
good
that's where i'm stuck
i'm stuck i'm stuck okay
and one more
what's the deeper truth to that you are
stuck
in your life and the truth of who you
are is you are stuck
it's the deeper truth
that was it okay there you are
overwhelmed
no no just who okay you were you were
down here right right well you went
that was right here okay that
is where you are now can you hold on to
that and
write your story
in other words you massage the
transformation line which is an i
statement you take it deeper deeper
deeper deeper as the answer to the
question what is the story of my life
and the truth of who i am and you get
rid of the end of the sentence because
we're not talking about
the
the rest of the sentence
when you got to i am stuck
and then i said what's the deeper truth
you felt it before you said it
and that's why you went whoo
because now you were
down there i you didn't even have to say
the words
you got there
now can you hold on to that and from
that place
of who
feel it
start to tell a story
any story
doesn't matter if you start to tell the
story from that place karen
your writing will be will change
okay
so what story pops into your head about
you being stuck
um
you want the exact information
just some information that i wasn't told
about my past
my upbringing tell me about it
right you know write it you're writing
it i'm right don't you just now when you
went well you went up
stay down with who
yeah stay down there
it's still pretty fresh i found out
about it accidentally
uh wasn't really probably supposed to
find out
and i found out and it made me you're
you're you're telling me okay i'm
chatting
for you
when did it happen who
uh i wanna know when did that who
happened
up maybe two months ago
tell me
tell me about it uh just
found out some information that was
shocking
and
really
didn't know anymore hi i didn't know who
i was after i found that out
keep going
and uh
i was angry that i wasn't told the truth
what was the truth you were told
probably don't want to say it because it
involves family
and they could be listening
put yourself in danger
well i had to confront someone
yeah
i had to confront somebody for covering
things up
and not keep being truthful okay this is
what people want will buy this is what
people will pay for they want that story
and they want the scene they want to
know what the person looked like they
want to know what the dialogue was they
want to know where you were what was the
lighting light what you know what did
the were there sounds
make a movie
of that scene
and and
as gert just said
be brave
be bold
and mighty forces will come to your aid
so when you massage your transformation
line and you keep going deeper and
deeper you're going to get to that
sentence where you're going to go
and then you start writing
in that voice don't go up
to the chit-chat voice
stay in that deep voice and write about
it
who was it where were you what was
happening etc now i know you don't want
to go into it here but that is what you
would do as a writer and that's what
people pay for
they don't care your smartness that's
not important they want the guts because
that's what they want
that's what they pay for
so you want them to buy your book
and look you look at all the books that
are best sellers that people have
cherished is because characters have
been in trouble characters have had a
conflict characters had to discover
things about themselves that they didn't
want to look at something happened they
you know it that's what makes drama
that's what makes literature
clever tales are not going to sell
but the deep truth of your life
will register with everybody because
everyone will go
yeah that happened to me too not exactly
that way but
sort of
hey joe you got to read this
brenda you got to read this book you got
to read this book you got to read this
book
because it suddenly becomes
about human beings who are in conflict
and sometimes it has a happy ending
where the character
triumphs learns to deal with it and
somehow it has a tragic ending
where the character
is unable to deal with it right
you're feeling it right now aren't you
yeah
if you can write from that place karen
you will make art
do you understand that yeah about a
transformation line now if you can get
to that deep place without the
transformation line
great that's just a technique i came up
with
but if you
but if you stumble onto an i statement
about a birthday cake
when my brother came home i was hiding
the birthday cake you get rid of the
birthday cake and now you got i was
hiding
what is this truth what is the story of
your life and the truth of who you are i
was hiding
not about a birthday cake
i was hiding in my life and then you
massage it and it takes you deeper look
how it brought you deeper we should have
the camera on you right now
glad i don't have mascara your eyes are
fillet full of tears and your heart is
your heart is in your throat yeah
now
right from that place don't go up
stay there and write and the writing
write like you talk don't try to be a
writer
just tell the story and it will be magic
and you practice it that's what i teach
people practice it and
at the end of the first class of the
first seven classes
that becomes an important tool for them
what do you think
yeah
maybe give it more time before you
worry about if it's something that's
now
i've got a line for you to say to me
okay
say that felt like therapy that felt
like therapy
but it's not therapy it's about how to
write something that people will buy
if you tell your therapist the story
that
you're not able to tell now but that you
would and you would tell it to your
therapist
the therapist isn't going to go
hmm
you know if you start with the image of
when you got in the car with your father
and then do the part with the mother
it'll be a lot better
that's not what therapy is about
my class is about making art right
writing something good so you might read
what you wrote and i would say wow that
was amazing but you know the part about
the father why don't you open with that
and then go to the thing about the
mother see because we are dealing with
this as a work of art i'm not responding
to you like a therapist i'm not a
therapist i'm not here to get you to you
know go through your feeling about being
stuck i'm here to use that as a conduit
to get you to write in the deep voice
because that voice is powerful and when
the reader hears it
when e f hutton talks
everybody listens
that deep voice
you could be on the beach
on a sunny afternoon and you're reading
a novel about a man in a prison wearing
an iron mask
the story will transport you the reader
to some place completely different
and every novel every story every poem
does that it's intimate
it connects to the reader you are
talking to the reader and nobody else
the reader feels like this is just for
me
in a way you don't say it literally but
you say to the reader
look
i have to tell you about something that
happened to me
i thought i was fine but then i realized
and i got stuck and my life has not
moved at all now there are some things
i'm going to tell you that i'm not going
to tell anybody else i'm only telling
you in this book
and some of the people in this story
they don't know about it but you will
know about it dear reader because you
and i have this bond and i'm speaking
only to you
that's the illusion you create with art
so
yeah
getting to the deep voice
might
make you feel emotionally
uh
concerned
but that's what it is to be an artist
an artist doesn't just create with the
mind the artist creates with their soul
with their being and you have to
that's what you have to suffer
they don't care if the dancers heels are
bleeding they just want the dancer to
jump up in the air and stay there for a
long time and then come down they don't
care if it was hard for them to do it
they paid 150 for these seats
that's what they want to see
and that's what your reader wants from
you they want blood
and you give it to him
you give it to him and then your book
becomes a best seller and you buy an
island in the pacific and retire
do you see what i'm what the point is
i'm making here
you know
because your stories are universal
they're everybody's story
but you felt the power of it didn't you
i did yeah
i'm not sure i'm ready to tell it but
well in the class you would you'd write
it
and then
in the class you'd read it
and you'd be trembling and you'd be
you'd feel like you're in danger
and then after you finish reading it
everybody would be moved and you'll go
hmm
i survived
i i'm okay
i told my story but i'm okay and they
love the story
okay
what else
i bought this
i bought this in an airport oh wow
they had one that said playwright which
i have here they had another one that
said arthur and i bought that one i
don't know where it is and there was
another one that said dog catcher and if
i could find it i'd wear it
but i can't find that one either so play
writer yeah play right yeah i think
playwright's way better than a dog
well i don't know you know
uh we we actually uh had a very
stressful day yesterday because
in the middle of the night someone
deposited a dog in our front yard
and we have a little wall about that
high that the puppy wasn't a little
puppy it was you know but a puppy
it'll be a bigger dog
they just dumped
and at six o'clock in the morning my
wife went to get the paper and she said
i need your help we got this puppy he's
been moaning and groaning and he's
scared and all the whole thing
and so we took it in and we fed it and
we were debating did we keep it because
we have a german shepherd and the two of
them weren't the german shepherd didn't
wasn't crazy about it
the german shepherd's name is penelope
and so we named the dog homer
and by the end of the day we were
exhausted we realized the the dog's not
house broken we don't have time to walk
it along with the other dog
it was a mess so
we finally decided we're going to have
to find someone who will adopt the dog
but
we love the dog so much within that one
day we both bonded that where are we
going to find someone who's going to
take good care of it that's tough yep
and
she went to the pet store where we bring
our dog and
the trainer there
he saw a picture we took a picture of
the dog he looked at me went that's an
australian cattle dog
they're very expensive and my wife said
would you like it would you like to take
it because we can't handle it
he said i've been looking for an
australian cattle dog that you know
i i've been looking for it he was so
thrilled and he's he's a trainer and he
and his wife came over last night and
they bonded and the dog is okay but
at the end of the day i said to my i'm
wiped out
yeah we've had that's how we had a cat
for like 16 17 years just showed up at
the door
stressed crying
and probably someone dumped it and um
i know yeah our first cat was like that
yeah she was under a house scared to
death
you know and that cat cleo
when
she she died um
she had been attacked by a dog and we
brought her to the vet and her wounds
were pretty bad and the vet said i'm
afraid she's probably not going to live
very long
and he said you want to leave her here
with us and i said no no we're going to
take her home and she will
if she passes away it'll be here in our
house so we took her home
and he said but
you know if she is going to survive you
have to give
this eye dropper in her mouth every hour
so i laid on the floor next to her
and every hour i didn't sleep that night
every hour i gave her a little bit of
this medicine
and at some point and then i would fall
asleep and then i'd wake up and give her
some more and at one point about four in
the morning i think it was when i went
to feel her
i could feel the body had
rigor mortis had said
it's that stiffness
she's dead
and i just stayed with her and then
about 6 30
my wife walked in and she said house
cleo
and
i said she died
and i started crying
i've never i don't think i've cried that
hard since i broke up with
somebody when i was a senior in high
school
i started crying so heavy
and then i realized what it was
i was crying for my father
because i never grieved for my father
because it's a long story but
i kind of skipped over the grief part
and i real and this is like 30 years
later here i am crying and i went i'm
crying for my father
and just
man it just came out
and uh and you know we put her in a box
and we
we buried her and so forth or had her
berry that kind of thing
but boy animals they can really rip your
heart out yeah they can and i've rescued
a lot of cats or we have and yeah um you
know they they appreciate it i don't
think i've ever i've only purchased them
from rescues i've never purchased a
purebred or anything yeah yeah we've
always rescued our pets chucky who we
had to put up had cancer we had to put
her down
she used to come up on my he used to
come up on my desk when i was working
and she would plop right down on my
checkbook
and rather than move her i would
try to write the checks and put them in
the envelopes without disturbing
uh him oh yeah we know all about it yeah
that's our daily right right animals man
yeah they're wonderful though okay
anyway you have yeah let me um okay
um
you have a concept you teach called
image moment
oh it's very complicated okay and it's
a cinematic it's a cinematic
construct in writing that most people
don't do
because it's not intuitive
something you have to learn to do
but it takes a moment in a dramatic
scene and how to
create psychological time
um
so that the reader is in that dramatic
moment as if it was a movie
like when you're in a movie and someone
says something and then there's a pause
and then say something else and it's
like wow one of those great moments you
know
oh red what will i do where will i go
pause
frankly my dear i don't give a damn
you know so when you're writing it
you're not making the movie you're
writing it
how do you create that pause
and that moment of drama
um
so that the reader feels they're
watching the movie and that they're in
the movie you know they're watching it
you and you create psychological time
the psychological time is the pause the
pause might only last a second in the
movie but psychologically it could last
forever
so the husband comes home and she says
i listen to your messages today you went
oh
she said are you having an affair
pause
uh no
so the drama
in that pause
how do you make that psychological that
real time which is only two seconds
psychological
so that it feels forever well there's a
way to now i have a lot of techniques
that you do and what you do it's a long
it's a long
mechanical construct but
image moment because you're creating a
moment using images
and creating psychological time
it takes people a while to learn how to
master it because most people want to
just tell their story and stopping and
doing an image moment
feels like they're not going with the
flow of their story so you have to train
people to do that
do you think that's what's missing in a
lot of let's say first time screenplays
or films is that psychological time that
pacing it's too fast a screenplay can't
create psychological time the filmmaker
can create it
all you can create in a screenplay is
dialogue
you can't tell the actors to pause you
can write it in the screenplay but it
doesn't mean they're going to listen to
you uh you you can say cinematic pause
here well the director may go
no we're going to do it my way so
you're not you're not in control all you
can control is the dialogue and
even then you'll have an actor who will
rewrite your line
but you can create a cinematic moment in
prose
where you create what appears to be like
a movie and
you can learn how to do it and once you
learn how to do it uh
and get over
all your impulses to not do it
because it's a technique you really it's
a tech just like in movie making you
have to know which lens to use
and you know when to go in for a
close-up and then it goes to the
editor's room and then they have to edit
it that that's technical that's very
technical and
the job of the editor who's editing it
is to make the scene on the screen not
look technical
he's got to make it work so you go
wow
major stross has been shot
pause
round up the usual suspects the end of
casablanca
so the editor cuts it in such a way that
you as a moviegoer feel the
psychological time so the image moment
technique i teach
is technical it's very technical and
when people learn to do it and they
finally get it
they're always amazed at how it works
and then
happens without fail
they'll say i was reading a book the
other day and there were like five image
moments on every page
because good writers know how to do it
but it's not intuitive
it's not something you intuitively will
know how to do
oh i'm sorry i was just
trying to put this it's so hard
one of the flaws in the design that i
never got that's really cool made
perfect that's really cool um
writing that'll live forever versus
writing that's a dead end you've made
that comparison with poetry i believe
writing you say that again sure
writing that'll live forever versus
writing that's a dead end
versus writing that's a dead end
is it is that what is your question
that's the question
let me try it again so
in other words
some writing lives forever and some
writing doesn't i think you said that
about poetry and you said sometimes
writers uh attempt to go for
writing that'll live forever but really
what they're doing is it's a dead end
how does a writer know that it doesn't
have to be poetry
or prose
any screenwriting i i don't know if i
have a wise answer to that some some
sometimes you
you don't know
um you know some some of the things you
do you might think
aren't going to be especially
uh relevant or memorable and for some
reason
uh
it lives for a long time and other
things that you think are the best thing
you ever did
ends up being forgotten so it's kind of
hard to know it's kind of like
a crapshoot
you do the best work you can and you
hope for the best
creativity is a process not a
prescription for product okay yeah i
don't say
you know
here's the finished product let's work
to make the product and a product has
this it has that it is this it is that
that's what most writing
classes do
uh matter of fact that's what most
literary criticism in the 19th century
did
and in the 20th century literary
criticism even
shifted to
what what are the techniques or the
devices
that the author used not what is it his
life about and the freudian implications
and the social menu of the time but what
are the devices
that the artist used to make that
product
well
i kind of go further back and go
the devices are something
that we write in in the process
toward product but we don't aim for the
finished product
we don't know where we're going to go
the creative
work is about the process
working on the concepts the exercises
not on a prescription for a finished
product
so the concepts i teach in method
writing are not
the end product they are the process
impulse
so all the concepts i teach not just in
level one and two that we kind of talked
about but in level three four and five
and then the levels beyond i have a
whole bunch of levels um
it's it's about the process i'm always
wanting the artist to honor the process
the way you work not what you're aiming
for but just let the truth
of the impulse of your process
find its way and then when you finally
get your novel or your story or your
poem
you won't have headed there
and my analogy in sports is in golf you
don't aim
you don't aim
to get the ball in the hole
you hit the ball correctly
you get the right club and you swing
correctly and if you do that
it'll go where it's supposed to go but
you don't aim to put it in the hole
so you you go through your process
and let the end result take care of
itself so that's what i mean when i say
the creativity is about the process
matter of fact isn't that the term they
use
they say the creative
process
so
if you come from the process
the product will emerge
and it will always surprise you
it will be unexpected
you didn't expect to be stuck
we started out with
um
uh i'm really thinking about da da da
and by the time we got through going
through some of the techniques of the
other side of the coin and and other
things i
didn't bring up you end up being stuck
and writing about that subject that you
didn't expect to write about
so that's what i mean by
it's not a prescription for product
it's so it's a process
just make sense it does do you see a lot
of writers that come in with the product
mindset
everybody ever you think everybody
starts out sure we're all human we all
have you know ideas things we want to do
most people have some kind of idea what
they want to write about and they're
always surprised
that
in some way they did do it but they took
a route they didn't expect
and if they had gone straight for it it
wouldn't have been what it ended up
being and that the
you know the unexpected path there
was what makes it interesting not
where they got
why is it important to outline the story
before you start writing it it's not
important
i would never suggest anybody do that
that's exactly what i just finished
talking about that's where you you're
looking at your product and and you know
fitting your feet into the shoes of the
right size and you're not in any
creative process at all i would never
tell anybody to outline your story
except there's two exceptions you would
make an outline of your story if you're
being paid
and this is the other component
because if you're just being paid and
this other component isn't there then
it doesn't apply you're being paid and
there's a deadline tomorrow
or at the end of the week
well
okay they're paying me they want me to
write a story about ballistic missiles
okay
i'll do the best i can with my talent
i'll outline what i need to do blah blah
blah i'll get it done in a week and i'll
make five thousand dollars
but if they're not paying me and there's
no deadline
why would i go with an outline for the
product when the creative process is
much richer and holds so many unexpected
marvels
that's what i want to bet on
i want to bet on that horse the
unexpected marvel that will come from
the unknown and the unexpected of the
creative process
why would i do if no one's paying me and
there's no deadline why would i
purposely sabotage my genius
which doesn't come out all the time
anyway
if ever
i'm not going to make an outline because
then i'm bound by the outline
so you don't need to know where you're
going
when you when you're writing a story
it's not about needing to know
you are better off if you don't know if
you know you're probably going to be in
trouble
it's like love
i'm not going to fill that blank tell me
i want to hear it
if you have a card
and every time with your date you keep
looking at the card always say something
funny okay you know it's it's got a list
of things you should do
that will
make your date want you
i mean that's ridiculous
you have to be in the moment and you
have to just be there be in the moment
see what happens
love always happens when you don't
expect it to happen
right yeah that's true
that's true so you don't think blind
dates work
you what you don't think blind dates
work
if they're kept blind
if you are open
a matter of fact i'm saying the opposite
i'm saying blind aches can work
listen to the stories that people tell
of how they met
you know people who've been together for
three four five years at least
i'll say you know i never expected that
he was my uncle's uh
neighbor and it was a wedding and he was
there and and he's not anything like the
person i thought i would fall in love
with
i thought it was going to be this this
and that and i don't know just something
happened and the next thing you know we
got five kids
you you can't
um
oh there's a s is it the supreme you
can't something about love what is it
it's just sorry love can't what you
can't hurry love you can't we can't hurt
sorry you don't want me to sing yeah
no
no you don't want me to sing it
you i would be happy to hear you okay
all right but people we can we can put a
link to the video for the song yeah no
you know if something is going to be
written written it's going to be written
don't be afraid yeah you got that story
about you when you went fishing with
your fight it'll it'll come through
don't don't worry about it
go with the unknown
and it'll come in when you least expect
it
but go with the unknown
that's the creative process
unless someone's paying you right and
there's a deadline
well
you know you're not you're not stupid
someone's gonna give me money to write
about ballistic missiles okay i'll do it
but otherwise i'm gonna go with the
unknown
so what about the people that say you
must have a road map for where you're
going
if not your story will not turn out and
i got a uranium mine that you must
invest in
somewhere out in nevada you give me ten
thousand dollars of your hard-earned
money and i'll make you a million
what would you say to that
can i go visit the mine
i would say you take me on a door i
would shut the door
so the same is true for the story you
i don't worry about it it'll come
through
and anyone who says you must know your
story you might
if you want to put your money in a
uranium on that's that's your business
but
you know
it's not what i teach
so i'm not saying
my way is the only way but it's what i
teach
what is the invisible motor
the idea that a work of art is a
mechanical thing um
that's an analogy i use but i discovered
it goes all the way back to the russian
formalists
who looked at the form rather than the
content in other words not the story but
the devices you use to make the story
come alive
and they felt that a work of art was
like a machine
and it worked as i said
uh and one of the analogies this guy
used the man named victor shlovsky
he said it was like a car
and
uh he said some other things but
i
go slightly slightly different direction
uh there's three things with the car
there's the engine
there's the inner
structure and decor and is what the car
looks like on the outside
what the car looks like on the outside
is your story
that's your story
a lot of people write their stories and
there's no engine and there's nothing
inside it's like a fake set on a movie
you know movies lot
that's the outer trappings of it but to
me
the motor that's under the hood
that's the invisible motor that
powers a poem or story
and when you work on your
story or whatever you're going to be
writing
the techniques that i teach
are the mechanics of that invisible
motor that powers your story
so that's what i mean when i say the
invisible motor and most writing classes
don't really go to the invisible motor
they go with the design of the car
the story how it looks on the outside
but they don't really get into writing
i want to make people better writers
not better
plotters
when you're on a plane and someone says
to you what do you do
you don't say oh i'm a plotter
i want you to be you know
the one who makes the story go because
of the engine
if i got in the car the most beautiful
car in the world turn on the key it
doesn't work i don't want the car it's
got to go what makes the car go
the devices
that we learn how to write in an
authentic voice then learn how to use
the other four voices then i have other
levels where i teach other devices but
these are devices that actually
facilitate the creative unknown
and what's the oil in that engine what
if i'm low on oil and now these gears
and these different parts are going to
start grinding and pretty soon the car
is going to stop working
good question no one's ever asked me
that what's the oil
whether it's synthetic vegetable
whatever i'm running on what what is
that oil that's keeping this story your
emotional truth
that's the oil
if it's not coming out of here
it's not worth it
it's just
imagination
which is good up to a point but it has
to have an emotional truth
what's the emotional truth
so that's the oil
okay
look at the oil you had a little while
ago that's true
i mean that was a lot of oil kiddo it
was it was an oil spill and
if you can hold on to that oil
not just for the story you would write
about being stuck but other experiences
you might write about that that same oil
applies
now your story is going to be compelling
for the reader
right you don't need an outline
you don't need a plot
you don't need that if you don't have
the deep voice
and you don't have the oil of some of
the other techniques the emotional truth
you're just
you're doing what uh
when jack kerouac
wrote on the road and he showed it to
truman capote it was he wrote it on
butcher paper you know rolls a butcher
paper which is just stuck in the
typewriter uh truman capota said that's
not writing that's typing
now he was wrong but that's a good
analogy and if you don't have the
emotional truth it's just typing
it's not writing
okay
but
the way you're nodding your head yeah
and but
i was actually thinking of the movie
kill your darlings which i did a show
part part of it had jackass i was trying
to picture what he was going through i
believe
he was that his character was in the
film so that's where i went to i was
thinking of right now um
did he go to france and people think he
was homeless or am i getting him talking
about jack kerouac am i getting him
mixed up with someone else where he went
to france and he became very
disillusioned because people thought he
was homeless no no i'm thinking of
someone no he lived with his mother okay
wrong person all his stories about him
being on the road
he went on the road a few times he
basically lived with his mother
and and and typed and timed but he drew
on his experiences
he was a great writer
and he drew on his experiences and
boy you read on the road and man that
that book is
the the poetry in it comes from the
emotion of his deep voice
just
every once in a while i read the last
paragraph on the road
you just read that last two or three
paragraphs the last page
man it's great
and i just read it and it sometimes
helps me find my voice
try it sometime what's this do you
remember what exactly the paragraph is
not word for word but
i i can't quote it
you'd have to read it if i had it here i
could read it but uh
um fair enough yeah you know
it's a beautiful beautiful piece of
writing
you know it's like a piece of music
sometime i will read
a paragraph or a page out of a book that
i know the way i would put some music on
because i know it somehow gets me in the
mood or it touches me in a certain way
so
same with writing i'll read something
and it just
i'll read the end of ulysses with molly
bloom's speech
where you know they're on this bluff and
he's been trying to
get her to make love to him and
finally she thinks oh what the hell
as him as anyone else what the hell and
then she asked him to ask her again
and he asked her and she said yes
i said yes i will
yes
i'll read those last words
in ulysses and man it just i hear the
rhythm of that voice it just really
connects me there's a lot of books
things that i'll go and read i'll read
the opening of dante's inferno midway
through the journey of my life i found
myself lost in a dark wood
i found myself
lost
in a dark wood
how do you find yourself by getting lost
i midway through the journey of my life
i found myself now
literally it means i i
suddenly i was
there you know like i found myself at
the east uh gate i found myself in the
back room you know
but if you think of it literally midway
through the journey of my life i found
myself lost
that's how i found myself by being lost
in a dark wood
you know in the dark truth of your soul
and
and of being stuck and where you went
when you went to the deep voice that's
your potent place
that's the oil that will make your
engine run
and if the engine is put together right
and you've got these techniques that you
know how to use
indy 500
winner
is that why you love writing poetry the
rhythm
of the writing the rhythm of the word
well the rhythm is the rhythm of the
voice
i mean that's the rhythm of the the deep
voice speaking to someone else in a very
intimate way
and
connecting with him
you know
um
i i talked about
my dog jessie who
um
she had cancer and we had to put her
down
it's in one of my books i like
i like different sizes i like when i'm
doing a book i like to think
what size do i want it to be like lucky
finds with all the cards now most most
of my books are going to be
you know the normal size of a book but
once in a while i i'm curious so like i
did a book of haiku oh yeah and i wanted
it to be a flip book so i i thought it
would be about
that thick
and it would be 50 haiku but it ended up
i wrote 300 haiku and i wrote a
introduction
that was uh close to 450 pages oh so
it's got a 450 page introduction and
then it's got 301 haiku and the
introduction is
what does it say here it says
um
in 201 chapters and 601 paragraphs
so
the little book i was going to do ended
up being like that and
it kind of grew so i i i kind of like
different things
this book is a smaller book too
and um
it has a
i think of it as a circus
the poems are all different and i have a
chagall painting in the front and on the
back it's got a roomy quote with passion
prey with passion make love with passion
eat and drink and dance and play
why look like a dead fish in the ocean
of god rumi
so i have a poem in here that is about
my dog
jesse this is not an earth-shattering
poem it's just about my dog jesse who
we had to put down
jesse my dog
i was driving back from a music recital
this evening
and found myself cruising down a street
i used to frequent 30 years ago
but haven't driven down since
so many of the places i used to go to
are gone
a favorite italian restaurant now a
fitness center
a bookstore now an antique store
a cafe where i read most of 100 years of
solitude now an ice cream parlor
it isn't as if i was planning to go to
any of those places but it makes me sad
to know they're gone
it doesn't really matter i'm 72 years
old
a lot is gone
it's all gonna go
eventually
by the cafe a boy was walking his dog
along the sidewalk
one day the boy will be gone along with
his dog
my dog is gone
jesse used to lie by my feet as i sat at
the computer trying to write a poem
she's gone now
no more jessie
after i'd written the poem i'd take
jessie out for her midnight walk
sometimes we'd pass a house and the
people inside might still be up sitting
at the table talking and drinking
but mostly the streets were quiet and
she and i would enjoy the night air
the way the leaves rustled when a wind
came up from the ocean
maybe a poem would be buried in
someone's front yard and jesse would dig
it up and bring it to me
like a bone she
just found
that poem
about the man in charge of watering
jesse dug that one up she just dug it up
and brought it to me what you got there
girl
she dropped it on the sidewalk then
trotted off
looking for more poems more bones
no more bones now
and few poems to be dug up except
this one
which is torn at the edges and i've
stopped caring about the line breaks or
the metaphors or even the kind of things
a poet is supposed to do when writing a
poem making everything ship shape
no more bones
no more ship shape i'm not even sure you
are reading this poem right now maybe
no one is reading it like i said earlier
it doesn't matter you know i write the
poems anyway
jesse will come back some night
take my poems on our walk
and bury them in someone's front yard
and all i'll have to do in my remaining
years
is walk my weary bones down the sidewalk
and dig them up
dig up those poems that jesse buried
my good girl talk
taking such good care of me then and now
jessie won't be with me but i'll thank
her
give her a good rub on the back
then
i'll let her go
see that's about my dog jesse that's
beautiful
so
it's not so much rhythm as the voice
you know
sometimes there are rhythmic things you
can do and that's part of your technique
so it depends if i'm doing to be read
and sung
you know the repetition then i would do
that
you know
it's also about loss and change
you know you talked about walking down
the street and the this restaurant isn't
here anymore and this bookstore has
changed well it's about i'm 70 i wrote
that when i was 72 i'm 78 now so i wrote
that six years ago it's about
thinking
you know as i said my dad died when he
was 54 and i i wasn't i always
thought i would live longer than he did
so
you know when i wrote the poem i was 72
and
you know i'm
feeling older your bones your body you
don't
you know i can't dunk anymore
you know i can't throw a football 70
yards
and so
you also think of what you can't do as
an artist that
you're getting older and
things are going to be gone you're going
to lose things friends will die and
loved ones will leave and
i was just thinking about that and
feeling all that uh and that jessie was
gone but um
i thought of how she would bury my poems
and then dig them up which is a metaphor
of course
[Music]
and that eventually had petter and let
her go that
at some point
the poems don't come anymore
and the muse that brings you the poems
whether it's your dog or the muse or
whatever
that will end too
and you have to
let it go you have to
give him a pet and
let it go
whether it's a poem or a lover
a loved one friend
whatever
what do you mean by the muse won't come
anymore
well the muse you know i don't i don't
believe in the muse but and i'm just
using that cliche that you know poets
sit and write and the muse comes and
gives you the poem i don't believe that
i believe that you
the muse is in you but i just use that
cliche as a kind of the idea that you'll
be sitting at your desk and
nothing will come to you anymore you
know the muses will say you know we got
to work with this guy in chicago he's
just 20 years old he's just starting out
uh you know take care of yourself jack
so i i i use that cliche that the
the muse
won't come anymore you you you you won't
have it
what an athlete can lose it a writer can
lose it you never know
but can you lose it for a while and get
it back i know the the writer's block
but is that really that the muse won't
come anymore well i look but we're
getting into technicalities here i don't
believe in writer's block okay
i can write a sentence
hemingway once said
uh when he had writer's block he said
he would write this down you've done
this before
you can do it again
all you have to do is write one true
sentence
he didn't mean true
factually
he meant a sentence that was
authentically
spoken and real and not trying to be a
writer and not trying to gussy it up
just saying the simplest thing you could
say
you've done this before you can do it
again all you have to do is write one
true line well
i don't have writer's block
you know why
because here's what i write
i got up this morning at seven o'clock
i don't feel like writing today
i don't have anything to write about
it looks like it's gonna rain and later
i have to go to ralph's to get a chicken
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
i don't know what i'm going to write
about but i don't care
i'm just i'm going to write well i don't
feel like writing i have nothing to
write about i feel like i have writer's
block but of course i never have
writer's block i don't know what it is a
big wooden thing inside my head
just write you don't have to have a
story you don't have to have an idea
just connect with that moment and maybe
you'll write crap but you'll write
i don't believe in writer's block i
don't believe in the muse and
inspiration and all of that stuff i
believe in the mechanics of art
i believe if you know how to hit a
a golf ball and you know how to hit
shoot a basketball and you practice it a
thousand times then even if you're not
in the mood you can pick up the damn
ball and shoot a hoop
i can pick up the damn club and
hit the ball maybe i can only hit it 10
feet because my bones are old and i'm
tired but i can do it
i don't have to have
i need to be inspired to play golf today
imagine if a professional athlete said i
only play
when when i'm inspired
you know there goes that million dollar
contract
why do people call themselves blocked
writers
i don't know i'm not
their therapist
they're operating under an illusion
they're not very professional
yeah if i get an injury i don't go and
play that day
but if i'm not injured
i play
i don't feel like it but i play
because i gotta play
according to the schedule
so i can get up and write
i've done it before
i can do it again
all i have to do is write one true line
i got up this morning at seven o'clock
i don't feel like writing today as a
matter of fact i have nothing to write
about it looks like it's gonna rain and
later i gotta go to ralph's to get a
chicken
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
it's not magic
do you think people romanticize being a
blocked writer
makes them more tragic makes them maybe
get some sympathy maybe but if they
write about it
that would be good there you go see if
you're right about it you know i feel
blocked today
all right
write about it
i just think you know if you can
physically
hold the pencil or type at your keyboard
you can write something
but what happens is when you think of
your product
and your outline
how am i going to get from point a to b
in my outline oh where am i going to
start and what happens when the door
closes and
oh god i have writer's block
i don't worry about that
we don't care about plot we care about
the human being in the story
yeah the human being is what matters if
the reader doesn't care about the human
being they could care less about the
plot everybody tries to come up with
plot
i mean plot's important
and
i could do a whole lecture on the
difference between plot and story there
is a difference story is the
chronological sequence of the events a
plot is how you arrange the sequences
and sometimes you don't always start at
the beginning go to the end sometimes
you start at the end and then you go to
the beginning and then you go to the
middle
you know then you have a flashback i
mean plot is
is is much different than story but
when you're writing
a story or your plot
if the human
if the protagonist whether it's first
person or third person
if the reader doesn't care about that
character
why would they care about the plot
they they care about a character
and then they want to see what's going
to happen to the character and that's
the story
so
character is most important every writer
will tell you that it's almost a cliche
grab any writer any published writer off
the street and say what's the most
important thing and they'll go character
now
once you've got your character
your character will lead you to your
story and to your plot
even if you've already got it made up
and figured out and outlined it
characters change their mind
characters don't always do what you want
them to do they will tell you what they
want to do and what they want to say and
all of a sudden your character
leaves for
tierra del fuego
and
i didn't plan on that but now they're on
a ship going to tierra del fuego and
they're meeting a
tall dark woman with a long cigarette
holder and a cigarette that has a long
ash whoa where do i go with that
you don't know it's accidental
so once you've got character
then
the character will create your plot
and where does character come from
character comes from the voice
if you're in the deep voice
and the character is narrating from the
deep voice or the third person narrator
is in the deep voice
that creates compelling character so
voice creates character
character creates plot
and it can be no other way right
can't reverse i would never say it can't
be any other way
what i'm saying is that in general
um
if your story does not have a character
that people relate to
your story isn't going to be enough
and the way you get people to relate to
a character is through the authentic
voice
they hear that intimate voice and
suddenly that character
is real and is alive
but i'm not gonna say it's the only way
it's the way i think it should be
because
that will succeed for you like i said i
don't think there's a writer out there
that will tell you character doesn't
matter
they're going to tell you character
matters
what are the steps to developing and
building a character
i actually teach a class in that
um
well one establishing the voice
how does that character talk
um how do they see the world
what is their attitude toward the world
and then you've gotta collect a lot of
details
that i have my students make a character
checklist
not for any one character but for any
character and you should be keeping this
checklist
for the rest of your life
anytime you see something that looks
interesting about a character or you
think about it or you see it in a movie
or you read it in the book make a note
of it
and then when you start developing your
character
riffle through your your checklist and
see what you got that's kind of
interesting
um
so
you want to find things that make the
character compelling because of
little little things what do they keep
in their refrigerator
how do they wear their clothes how do
they eat eggs
how do they eat sunny-side up eggs so
you should be paying attention you know
a lot of writers that they don't pay
attention
they've been to a coffee shop or cafe a
hundred times and they've never really
looked at how people eat
if you look at how people eat
everybody eats a particular way the way
they hold the fork the way they cut
their food
sunny side up eggs
you should watch
10 different people eat sunny side up
eggs and every one of them will do it
differently
i saw one guy
he cut the white
put it on the fork
dipped it into the yolk okay
and eat it and
the yolk would come up
white yo so he would he kind of kept
doing that
i saw another guy
eat the white without touching the yolk
never touched the yolk until all he had
was the yolk in the center of the plate
and then he took his fork and he slid it
under the yolk
picked it up and i tell you i get the sh
to me there's
i couldn't do that
gets his fork under the yoke
and the whole thing like he'd been
waiting the whole meal to get to that
yolk now to me yolk creeps me out i've
got to mix it up
when i was a kid
my dad would have to cut it all up for
me because i didn't even want to dip it
in the i wanted it all cut in little
pieces and all mixed together it would
be a scrambled sunny-side up egg and i
would eat it that way
dipping my toast into it uh if you look
at people eat their food you'll find a
lot so you could do a checklist on
hundreds of little things
about people what does their
refrigerator look like everybody's
refrigerator is looks differently and
when i go visit a friend or anybody's
house even if it's a stranger you know
someone says oh let's go over my
friend's house or something
i look at their refrigerator and i look
at their medicine cabinet oh and i look
at their books oh interesting i can tell
more about a person by their medicine
cabinet their refrigerator and the books
they have than anything else
whatever they are acting like i know i
know about them by that now
as a writer i'm going to make notes of
things i find interesting so that
i'll use that in a book for a character
you know people who have 10 day old milk
in the back or
or they have lots of uh tupperware and
everything is in there and it's going
it's already moldy
you know how do people arrange their
refrigerator some are are you know
obsessive-compulsive they've got
everything neat and perfect
so same with the medicine cabinet boy
cabinet tells you everything oh like you
know somebody's got a tube of cream
that's been blick and the cream hasn't
been used in about a year but they've
kept it because
who knows that rash may come back and
you can see the top the cream that was
squished out of the top is now brown and
it's
you know they didn't even press it
neatly or something one guy's got his
toothpaste and he rolls it as he goes
another person is squishing it here and
there and it's a mess so there's all
sorts of little eccentricities that you
can find in a medicine chest
make a note of them and keep it on your
checklist because one day you'll be
writing a story and you'll have a minor
character
and
you'll have an opportunity to mention
something in their medicine chest that
will be interesting what about books
what does that tell you about well i
always look at books see what people are
reading
you know i mean you never know what
people read
and and you always you'll find anomalies
too
you'll you'll find all their books about
one subject
and then they got one book on aristotle
and you go hmm what are they reading
aristotle for but then they'll have
another book on how to make a million
dollars in the stock market or something
you know you just oh this person's got
one of their books that they must have
read in first grade and they've
jimmy potts gets a haircut
and you open it and it's got little
illustrations in it and it's a story
about a kid
who gets a haircut and the barber
made a bad cut and some woman thinks he
was hit by a truck it's you know it's a
story for like a third grader and he's
still got it i wonder why
gee i'll use that in a novel one day
so
you make notes of things that you think
are are interesting
and you put it on your checklist and you
have hundreds of things on your
checklist
all sorts of things uh just their
emotional truth and just their anything
and then when you start writing a short
story and you got a character you think
all right what have i got on my
checklist maybe i can use some of this
stuff
you know the way they clean their
glasses
the way they wear their glasses
um
the inside of their car
well that's another
thing like a medicine chest
the inside of the car i mean i knew one
guy every time i'd get in his car i'd
say
why don't you grab a shovel and dust up
you know
it was that
you know it looked like uh
what do you call the junkyard
or the ones with the serial killer clean
where you're like whoa
this thing's been get in the car that's
absolutely pristine yeah wow a little
freaky well i don't know i think i
admire this person oh okay they really
worked hard
i'll have a penny on the mat on the
you know not the driver's seat but over
there it's been down there for like
months and i just don't feel like
picking it up
and i kind of got used to being it down
there
i figured i'm not going to pick it up
let's see if someone else picks it up
and if someone else does pick it up i'll
go ah okay
character interesting
some people won't let sleeping dogs lie
and some people won't let lying penny
sit
so you know you find out little little
things that that are interesting um
i read a a detective novel a few years
ago a few years ago 30 40 years ago
and it was about
a character who's a main character in
all his detective novels who is a
detective and a crooked sheriff in a
small town in florida throws him in jail
for something
so
he's in jail for like two days and
he's just trying to keep his sanity and
figure out who did the murder
but in order to keep himself occupied he
thinks of things
and one of the things he thinks about
and it's a two-page essay
you're not old enough to remember this
but when i was a kid and you had skates
nowadays skates are attached to shoes
you just put your foot in the shoe
that's got this the roller skates
attached to it but when i was a boy
you had the metal skates that had little
clamps on it and it hooked your shoes
not tennis shoes you had to have shoes
that had you know rims on them that you
could hook it on and then the way you
would tighten it would be with a little
thing that looked like a little wrench
called the skate key
and you always had to have the skate key
with you because you never knew when it
would
change and the skate would fall off and
you'd have to unscrew it put it back on
your shoe and then screw it again so
where did you keep that skate key well
90 of the kids who skated took the skate
key there was a little hole in it and
they put a string in it and then they
would tie the string around their head
and this skate key would hang here
he wrote two pages on a skate key
i don't remember anything about that
novel
except that essay on a skate key has
nothing to do with the story totally
irrelevant to the story
except it tells you something about his
character
and it became interesting
so
little things can be very fascinating in
books even a detective novel where i
remember that and i've forgotten
everything else
or latch key kids used to have the the
string
you know you could always tell in the
80s the latch key kids yeah you know
and and the latch key kids would have a
string with the key right exactly and
they we were told to hide them so that
people didn't know that you'd be going
home alone right
yeah
my observations yeah and an extra
quarter in your pocket in case you had
to call your mom right for a payphone
now every kid's got
an iphone sure i remember driving around
somewhere where i was because i had to
call my wife or maybe the person i was
living with i had to call him to tell
him i was going to be late and you're
looking for you know a little pay phone
sometime in a movie when that happens
i'll think to myself why didn't they
just call them on their iphone
and i go oh it's 1972. there is no
iphone
yeah i remember being on the phone
trying to call my grandmother letting
her know quote everything was okay
it was in a little bit of a rough part
of town and somebody was making a
nefarious deal and yelling about it the
paper next to me
and i'll never forget he was really
angry and i'm thinking
and my grandma was like is everything
okay oh yeah everything's fine
but that's la you know at that time with
the pay phones i don't know it could be
anywhere but you see what just happened
i talked about a skate about stuff in in
a medicine chest how you eat eggs a
skate key and then you thought about the
latch key and then we got into the
calling on the phone and you remembered
how you had to call your grandmother to
say everything's fine
and someone is yelling over there doing
some kind of drug deal or something it
was bad yeah there's a scene from a
novel
yeah and and which has nothing to do
with the story but it it might be the
the event
that the reader never forgets
don't forget your plot sure but they'll
not they'll never forget that moment
where you're on the phone trying to tell
your grandmother you're fine and there's
a drug deal going on there and
somebody's yelling and screaming and
you're not exactly in the best part of
town right
because
a phone is a phone yeah oh yeah you
found the phone go make the call they
used to have three in a row you know
you'd go and then this person came after
i already got on the call and right i'll
bet you a hundred dollars that if i give
a young person today
a a quarter
and say there's a pay phone i want you
to make a call on the pay phone okay
they put the quarter in
then the dial the number
hi hey bill
yeah i'm i'm calling from a pay phone i
just i'm i'm
we have a bet going here okay
all right i just yeah i'm fine i'm fine
okay hang up
none of them
will check the little coin thing to see
if the quarter came back right
but when we did it when we were young
you did it because sometimes the quarter
would drop back into that little thing
and you'd get your quarterback right it
was such a treat but they wouldn't do
that because it wouldn't even occur to
them
sure
but those are little details too that
details everybody every writing teacher
will tell you details
what's the first writing exercise you
give to your students
they read the first three chapters of
the method writing book and they have to
write a journal entry in which they
write like they talk
how long is the journal entry
uh it could be 500 pages but for the
sake of the class
they can only read two pages
because otherwise they could be reading
100 pages and would be there all night
but i don't say you you can't
you know
write as much as you want in your
journal for that day or that week but
for the class
limited to about 500 words which is
about two pages so that we can respond
to it
which is 500 is a pretty good
normal chunk
but just a journal entry just write like
you talk
i i i want to hear your voice if you're
not writing like a talk we will point
out those sentences where you had uh he
skillfully said you know adverbs
adjectives all that writerly stuff we'll
point it out and we'll we'll try to get
you not to do that
and
then in anticipation of the next chapter
we start identifying transformation
lines
and then the following week they have to
write a journal entry writing like you
talk but massaging a transformation line
and sorry the transformation line again
is
i was hiding the birthday cake
get rid of the birthday cake what's the
story of your life and the truth of who
you are i was hiding
i didn't want people to see me i was
afraid they wouldn't like me if they saw
who i was they would hate me
i'm not a good person
i'm a bad boy
well i was hiding ends up
because i remembered being locked in the
closet and i'm a bad boy that's just
that's the bottom story of my life
i'm hiding because i don't want people
to see me i don't want people to see me
because they'll know who i am if they
see who i am inside they know i'm a bad
person
and then suddenly it came to me i'm a
bad boy
well that's a long way from i was hiding
i'm a bad boy and then from i'm a bad
boy
i'm stuck
which is where you ended up right so
that's i'm teaching them how to massage
a transformation line
then we do uh then we do the image
moment for two weeks because it's hard
and then we do something called dreaded
association which is another two weeks
again too complicated to go into now but
it was originally called the association
exercise and when i would assign it to
people and they would read it
they would get notes from their mother
as to why they were sick and couldn't
come to class
because they would dread it so
so then i
as a joke i called it the dreaded
association exercise
and that's what we call it and then of
course they do it and they bring it to
class and they're
they're just
shocked as hell how good it works and
what they can do with it and how it can
be a very creative thing and those are
the four concepts in the first level
write like you talk massage
transformation line image moment and the
dreaded association exercise
how many of your students are actually
able to write in a journal and not
censor themselves and not try to be too
writerly
eventually all of them
but in the beginning is that something
that a lot of them struggle with many of
them
don't have a problem with it they they
they haven't had enough experience
writing
that uh they know
how to be writers
the ones that have been writing a lot
and who think of themselves as writers
or i'm an actor
you know they might have a little
difficulty
or it might just be a sentence or two
here and there
and so we pointed out i talk about the
structure of the sentence and why that's
written and not spoken that if you were
talking you would have said it this way
or it would go this way or that word
would be there so we get into the
structure of the sentence and the
difference between speech and how we
write for instance
here's a sentence that is
absolutely
fine you'll see it in in books all the
time
it begins with a participle phrase
standing by the window i could see it
was going to rain nothing wrong with
that sentence great sentence
but we don't talk that way
we don't begin sentences with participle
phrases
we don't say
uh yeah i came home and standing by the
window i could see it was going to rain
that's not how we structure a sentence
when we talk what we say is i was
standing by the window and i could see
it was going to rain or when i stood by
the window i could see it was going to
rain but never
standing by the window comma i could see
it was going to rain that's not how we
talk so we get into the structure of
sentences how it's not always a word
you know because everybody has different
vocabularies so it's not about that it's
about the structure of the sentence how
a sentence is structured and once you
start to hear
that the deep structure of speech as
opposed to the deep structure of a
literary construct it doesn't mean it's
bad writing it just means
you have to know the difference
then if you know the difference you can
choose when to do one and when to the
other so maybe at the worst uh a few
people will have one or two of those
sentences somewhere in what they write
and we deconstruct it and we talk about
it so basically i'm getting them to be
aware
of of their writing
that is speech-based now it's not always
going to be that level two goes into
those four tones that are not like you
talk so
we're writers and we can do that too but
first we want to like acting we want to
have a good foundation
so where you write like you talk
once in a while i'll get someone who's
been writing a long time
and they're really locked into their
style
and it's hard for them to shift out of
it to because they think
they just think it's natural to throw in
those adverbs and adjectives and so
forth but
when you there's it's not good writing
sometimes
so sometimes even their writing writing
is not good writing
but most people take to it pretty well
why is it not good writing when when
someone's writing
to writerly to to using different terms
that we wouldn't use in normal
conversation uh if you've got a laptop
around
google stephen king
adverbs
he's got an essay on it
it's what amateurs do it's bad writing
so don't take my word for it
stephen king who's a good writer by the
way
excessive use of adverbs is the mark of
an amateur
um
uh elmore leonard
he had an article in the new york times
review of books
which was all about the 10 things that
bad writers do
the first one was excessive use of
adverbs and often adjectives i mean you
have to have adjectives sometime but you
got to be careful
um
it was so
well received
that his publisher made it a book
now how do you make a book
out of one page article in the new york
times reviewer book books i'll tell you
you have illustrations on every page
you have type that's very big
and the paper is about as thick as a 2x4
and then you get a book
and it's sold really well
and number one is excessive use of
adverbs and adjectives so
you know this is not something that i
made up while i was living in a cave
every every professional writer will
tell you that you can you can spot an
amateur when they overuse
adverbs
and often
even the adjectives
so
who am i to argue with stephen king
and elmore leonard
it's bad writing
now there's other things that may not be
bad writing but it's not how you talk
so that's a different thing i want
people to know the difference so that
they can control
when they're writing what effect they're
going to create
he mumbled he uh averred
uh he implied
he he shrugged
you know
uh i don't care if you live or die he
shrugged
so instead of saying a word that has to
do with uttering it's it's a physical
action i mean
writers do that bad writers do that all
the time and you know i feel like
sometimes i got to go
quit it
so keep it simple
well that's a different issue oh okay
you can say complicated things but you
say it like you talk
i'm not saying you can't write
complicated sentences okay
okay it's just a question of is that
speech or is that a literary construct
that came when people started to write
the difference
one of the problems a lot of people have
with marcel proust
is his fancy
language
if you read him fast
you realize he's writing like he talks
there's a great deal of eloquence in
there but if you read it fast you
realize
oh
he's talking
and
the elegance that you think you're
seeing is often just long sentences
some sentences are half a page but he's
talking
you would ask me about another book uh
books i've read so another one that i
read during the pandemic where
it was on the libby app for the library
was my salinger year so it was about a
woman who worked at a publisher in i
think the 90s and her job was to respond
to jd salinger fans and it's so great
they made a film and has
margaret quality in it and uh right
sounds funny to see it yeah but but she
wanted to take care in responding to
these fans because they were so
emotional and they were so invested
right in holden caulfield and she found
that a lot of them didn't want to hear
what she had to say they wanted to just
have this image of what
that character was and what the book
meant right
to help them character creates plot and
voice creates character
salinger never wrote another book in
that voice
if you read franny and zoe and raise
high the roof beams carpenters it's a
completely different style and voice
if you read some of his short stories
like uncle wiggly in connecticut or the
laughing man
it's not holding caulfield at all it's
not that style that that was holden's
voice it's unique and it's what makes
his character so unique the voice
you get the voice you get the character
you get the character the plot will take
care of itself
yeah in fact they became very angry she
was trying to help them yeah and they
didn't want help they wanted to be angry
and they wanted to be with holden they
wanted to be with holden
yeah it was really fascinating book yeah
looking forward to seeing the films
uh
wait the challenger years yeah
no my salander year and it's based on
this woman in new york city in the 90s
yeah it's really i don't think they're
ever going to make a movie of catcher in
the rye until
when his book goes in the public domain
or something because he won't allow that
he's dead now but i think he has
explicit instructions it's not to be
sold to the movies
yeah he had very rigid rules i believe
it sounds like he was a nice man the way
she described him in the book i don't
know
his urban legend might have been
different but he
he treated her well and so she just had
very little interaction at the
publishing house right but it was
fascinating and
just you know those things are kind of
really not important whether the writer
is a nice man or not
writers can be
son of a you
we may not realize it but it really
doesn't matter what matters is the world
they create
i don't care what salinger was like i
love holden
i love holden interesting
so he created something that was real
for me and that's
that's all you can ask an author to do
a writer should reach the reader it's
not just about making themselves feel
good or looking good to their peers it's
about reaching the reader it's all of
that
i mean you do want to impress your peers
i mean we're human
we want other writers
you know our peers to appreciate what
we've done
obviously i want people to like my
poetry but it means a lot to me if
another poet who i admire really thinks
my poetry is good okay
and i do want to reach my readers
but at the same time i want to satisfy
myself if if
if what i did
a writer
sculpture painter
makes me happy and
i met the challenge then
i'll move on
at some point you can't really go by
what people think of your work you have
to do it because it's your calling it's
what you have to do
but who wouldn't want someone to like
their work
but is there a certain point where
an author
an artist becomes so controversial
that it stops being about their work and
now it's just the legend of the artist
the mystique around them
the reputation whether it's true or not
okay and if that's true what what are we
going to do about that and that's what
i'm asking yeah what should should
someone do if their their work is
transcended to that point
look
everything is going to happen under the
sun
you know
there's nothing i mean i i can't
pontificate and say well it should be
this way or it should be that way or it
shouldn't be this way it shouldn't be
that way
you know what's going to happen and
sometime it's out of the writer's
control things happen that they didn't
expect
or they didn't want and sometimes they
want that they they act a certain way
and there becomes a legend about how
they are and they cultivate that legend
uh you know i mean
writers are people
and you know people are crazy
not every crazy person writes a novel
but some of us do
it doesn't make us saying just because
we can write a novel
who was the artist that did the lacma
lights chris
yeah so he did that
yeah chris chris brooke right burton
yeah chris i love him i love him right
chris bernstein i would have never
expected that to be as
iconographic and as popular as it is he
did something that somehow
captured the imagination of people and
transcended
it being one a spectacle and two a work
of art it's something beyond that
because on some level it's like
a bunch of lights what's the big deal
with that
and on another level it's
i mean it's not art what is it well it's
a place people like to go to well
less like a ride at coney island what's
the difference
you know i don't know but
art sometimes
uh connects to people in ways that we
don't really anticipate or or understand
there's just something about art that
i don't know you just
it
like like duchamp's uh urinal
you know he puts this urinal in a room
in a museum and
um
it's done
you could copy that
and do something you know put something
else in there that would be so
ridiculous
but he did it it's done
he put a urinal in an army scene it's
very famous
so
painters and sculptors
as filmmakers they do something and
sometimes you can't you can't you can
analyze it all you want but
there's an area that's unexplainable
and i love the light thing that i mean
i love to see people there
uh i remember there was a
uh what was it it wasn't a blackout but
it was something and it was it was the
only thing in the area that was lit
and people were just
having so much fun there
so
you know it's weird it's just
have you have you seen the car thing
the cars haven't been to lacma in a
little bit oh i don't know if the cars
are still there
um did you see the film with the guy
with the time with the clock it was
called the clock
and it exactly
went with the time on clocks and it was
a 24-hour film
didn't see that one
i mean it
it was an experience
i i i
i went i was in paris a year later and
it was being held in paris at the time
but it's just a series of shots from
movies that have a clock in them
a time
and as you watch it the time on the
clock is exactly what time it is
over a 24-hour period so it begins in
the morning and and it ends at midnight
um
you know it begins to
well it begins at midnight but then it
ends at midnight uh
the first five minutes you're bored
and you're thinking
i can't i'm not gonna be able to sit
here for another five minutes
and before you know it you're there for
two hours three hours and it's riveting
it's unbelie
who would have thought to do that
it's called the clock i mean it's it's
in the beginning you couldn't see it all
24 hours because you could only see it
during the hours that the museum was
open
so if the museum opened at nine in the
morning and it closed at eight at night
uh at eight at night uh
they would say okay folks you gotta
leave or you'd get there at eight in the
morning you could see it from eight but
you would never get to see what happened
after eight or
after midnight you know
but then the closing so i'd gone several
times and saw two or three hours of it
at different times
and then they said they were going to
show all 24 hours at the museum the last
day
and i was there for the whole 24 hours
oh wow and at the end
there were i would say a quarter of the
theater were people who'd been there the
whole time
and
when it was over with we all stood up
and cheered
and were hugging each other like you
made it and
it was one of those transcendence
experiences i've never forgotten it and
it's utterly ridiculous
i mean who would want to watch that
every every scene was two seconds five
seconds maybe 10 seconds and it was a
clock it could be someone looked at
their wrist watch could be a grandfather
clock clock on a train station just
scenes that had no connection at all
how could you watch five hours of that
it became mesmerizing it was
unbelievable i tell you one of
one of the most amazing things i ever
saw
what year was this
two
thousand something
early
maybe 20 years ago
something like that
yeah
okay but i don't know if when they'll
show it again but if they will people
will go to you know
it toured all over the world
so
but your question was about
you know when an artist creates
something you you never know what's
going to happen
you never know what's going to catch
people's imagination i don't even know
why we all stood up and cheered
and and were hugging each other
at the end maybe because we had been
there for 24 hours and maybe because we
were able to endure it i don't know what
it was but it was a feeling of of
exaltation
it was amazing
yeah
i've never experienced that before
because when when i saw it normally you
would just walk out at some point or if
you were there like it's six o'clock at
night at eight o'clock the guy would
come in and go okay folks we have to
close it down the museum is closing
so there was no like experience
um but for that there was it was amazing
did you stay up the full 24 hours
that was the when it did the last show
they specifically said it was going to
be 24 hours
before it was at the museum you could
only see it during the museum hours
consequently you were only seeing
like if the museum opened at nine
the first image you saw was nine o'clock
and as the day wore on it would be ten
one three five you could stay from nine
to eight
but you you'd still miss a lot and i
never did stay more than four hours
so when i went i would stay three maybe
four hours and i'd go with friends and
we would get loaded or something and
watch it or something but
that last night when it was going to be
24 hours i
made i plan to be there for the whole
thing
um i think there was one point where i
knew i had seen that
twice
an hour i'd seen it twice
and i left and got myself something to
eat and then i came back and my seat got
taken so i had to stand against the wall
but then eventually someone left and i
sat down
it was amazing read about it
the clock
check it out google it
you